Welcome to our second drink of customer survey and not toot our own horn. But here I go. Toot to toot toot. This is a fantastic episode, lady. It is. It really actually is, yes. Stephen Merchant joins us on the podcast. It's such a fun interview.
欢迎收听我们的第二期客户调查节目，虽然有点老王卖瓜、自吹自擂的意思，但我要开始了。嘟，嘟嘟嘟。这真是一集精彩的节目，女士。确实。它真的就是，是的。斯蒂芬·莫昌特作客我们的播客。这是一场非常有趣的采访。
He shares how we met Ricky Jervais and then how they came to co-create the UK version of the office. And then we, of course, ask him all about directing this hilarious episode. And he shares the inspiration for that amazing. but-licker scene. And when we asked you all what your favorite scene was from this episode, so many of you wrote in to say that it was the but-licker scene. For example, Miranda D. from Australia said, ladies, my favorite moment from this episode is the bit where Dwight, Michael, and Jim are in the conference room doing the mock phone call. It is so hilarious seeing Michael and Dwight get so
他分享了他是如何结识瑞奇·热维斯，以及他们后来如何共同创作英国版《办公室》的。然后，我们当然问了他所有关于执导这一搞笑集数的事情。他还分享了那场精彩绝伦的“舔屁股”场景的灵感来源。当我们问大家这一集中最喜欢的场景是哪个时，好多人都写信说最喜欢舔屁股的那个场景。比如来自澳大利亚的米兰达·D说：“女士们，这一集里我最喜欢的时刻就是德怀特、迈克尔和吉姆在会议室进行模拟电话通话的那段。看到迈克尔和德怀特完全
lost in the bit, especially because Michael is showing his love of improv. Yes, and Arena E. from Los Angeles says, office ladies, I have been a listener since the beginning, and I love everything about the show. Thank you, Rina. And she goes on to say, I finally decided to go back to the first drinks. Is that a thing of the show? So I could submit all the questions I'm always thinking of when I listen. I have been waiting for this episode to get to second drink so I could tell you this. My husband and I find the line but liquor, our prices have never been lower. So funny. So you know how sometimes a dog will just decide to lick their butt at the most inappropriate time. Every time our dog does this, we say to him, Rusty, have your price has never been lower?
沉浸在即兴表演中，真的太搞笑了，尤其是迈克尔展现了他对即兴表演的热爱。”是的，来自洛杉矶的丽娜·E说：“办公室女士们，我从一开始就是忠实听众，我喜欢这个节目的方方面面。谢谢你，丽娜。”她接着说道：“我终于决定回顾前几期的节目了——这算是个节目惯例吗？——这样我就可以把我听节目时总想问的所有问题都提出来了。我一直盼着这集播到第二期，好把这事告诉你们。我和我丈夫觉得‘舔屁股，我们的价格从未如此低廉’这句台词太搞笑了。所以你们知道有时狗狗会突然在最不合时宜的时候舔自己的屁股吗？每次我们的狗这样做时，我们都会对它说：‘拉斯蒂，难道你的价格从未如此低廉吗？’”
Very confusing to anyone who doesn't get the reference, but hilarious to us every time. Love, love, love the podcast and your incredible camaraderie with one another. Well, Rebecca L from Maryland wrote in to say that, first of all, Rebecca also loved the scene. but Rebecca has a background catch. Rebecca said, ladies, did you catch Rain almost breaking in this scene? I can see him start to laugh at 8 minutes, 44 seconds in the original version. It is right after he has to yell that the prices have never been lower. Lady, I went and rewatched it and I totally saw it.
对于任何不懂这个梗的人来说会非常困惑，但对我们来说每次都笑死。爱死、爱死、爱死这个播客了，还有你们之间那种不可思议的默契。好了，来自马里兰州的丽贝卡·L写信说，首先，丽贝卡也很喜欢这个场景。但丽贝卡有一个“细节捕捉”。丽贝卡说：“女士们，你们注意到雷恩在这个场景中差点笑场了吗？在原版视频第8分44秒时，我能看到他开始笑了。就在他不得不大喊‘价格从未如此低廉’之后。”女士，我特意回去重看了一遍，我完全看到了。
Rain is so clearly about to laugh and he's trying to hide his smile. He sort of covers his mouth by like leaning onto his. fist on the table. Yes, he's doing the Mindy. That's the Mindy move. Yeah. Yeah. Well, everyone, we pulled a clip of the moment where Rain almost breaks. We didn't play this in our first breakdown, and it's just so hilarious. We thought we should hear it. Hello? Hello, this is Dwight Shrut from the Dunder Mifflin Paper Company. Wow, that's great, because I need paper. Excellent. Then you are in luck, because we are having a limited time offer only on everything. Wow, this is my lucky day. Ask him his What is your name, sir?
雷恩很明显快要笑了，他在极力掩饰自己的笑容。他把手肘搭在桌上，用手挡住了嘴。是的，他在模仿明迪。那是明迪的标志动作。对，对。好了各位，我们截取了雷恩差点笑场那一瞬间的片段。我们在第一次剧情解析时没播这个，但它实在太搞笑了，我们觉得应该放出来听听。喂？喂，我是邓德米夫林纸业公司的德怀特·施鲁特。哇，那太好了，因为我需要纸。太棒了。那你有福了，因为我们正在对所有商品进行限时特惠。哇，今天真是我的幸运日。问他的名字。你叫什么名字，先生？
I am Bill Butlicker. Really, that's your real name? How dare you? My family built this country, by the way. Be respectful, Dwight, please. Yes, Michael. Did you hold on one second? That's my other line. What? No, but I...
我是比尔·巴特利克（屁股舔）。真的，这是你的真名？你怎么敢这样？顺便说一句，我的家族建成了这个国家。请放尊重点，德怀特，拜访。是的，迈克尔。你能稍等一下吗？我的另一条线在呼叫。什么？不，我……
Hello? Yeah. No, I'm just on the phone with this stupid salesman. He's so dumb. Probably just gonna keep him on the line forever and not buy anything. Okay. It's up to you to change his mind. Sorry.
喂？对。不，我正跟这个愚蠢的销售员通电话呢。他太笨了。大概会一直在电话里晾着他，什么也不买吧。好了。该你改变他的主意了。抱歉。
That was a family emergency. Oh, no, what's wrong? You know what? That's private. Boundaries, Dwight, come on. I'm sorry, Mr. Butler. As I was saying, we're having a limited... We have to speak up a little bit louder, I'm hard of hearing.
刚才有个家庭紧急情况。哦，不，怎么了？你知道吗？那是隐私。注意分界线，德怀特，拜托。对不起，巴特利克先生。就像我刚才说的，我们正在进行限时……我们需要大声一点，我有点耳背。
He's hard if he's an old man. Okay, as I was saying, right now... Yeah, you have to talk louder. Okay, our prices have never been lower. You have to talk louder. Never been lower. Louder, son! Buttlicker!
他耳背，如果他是个老头的话。好吧，正如我刚才所说的，现在……对，你得大声点。好吧，我们的价格从未如此低廉。你得大声点。从未如此低廉。大声点，儿子！巴特利克！
Our prices have never been lower! Stop it! Pete! That is totally inappropriate. You never yell at the client. Now, you listen to me, sir. It's so good. So good.
我们的价格从未如此低廉！住手！皮特！这太不合适了。你绝不能对客户大喊大叫。现在，听我讲，先生。太棒了。太棒了。
Well, Rebecca, we love that background catch and the journey it took us on. And I have another background catch, but this one is actually from the cold open scene. You know when everyone gathers around to ask Michael how we propose to Holly and then Michael spends this crazy yarn? Yes. We actually played the clip in our breakdown because it's so funny. But Dylan Kew from Annapolis, Maryland pointed out something. really interesting. Quote, in the cold open, Michael says that he gave his girlfriend the Heimlich maneuver because he's CPR trained. But a few episodes later, the whole office received CPR
好吧，丽贝卡，我们很喜欢这个细节捕捉以及它带给我们的奇妙旅程。我还有一个细节捕捉，但这个其实来自片头场景。你知道大家围过来问迈克尔是怎么向霍莉求婚的，然后迈克尔就开始扯了一大堆荒唐的故事吗？是的。我们在剧情解析里其实播过这个片段，因为它太搞笑了。但来自马里兰州安纳波利斯的迪伦·休指出了一件非常有趣的事情。他说：“在片头中，迈克尔说他给女友做了海姆立克急救法，因为他受过心肺复苏（CPR）培训。但几集之后，整个办公室才接受了心肺复苏培训，而迈克尔明显根本不知道这个培训是怎么运作的。这是因为客户调查本来应该排在缓解压力之后吗？还是说女士们觉得这只是个失误？我从第一天就开始听了。你们的解析过去常常让我觉得我一边上班一边在看《办公室》。”好吧，首先，迪伦，这是一个非常非常厉害的细节捕捉。简直是A加级别的捕捉。是的。我回去看过了。
training, and Michael clearly has no idea how this training works. Was this because customer survey was supposed to come after stress relief? Or do you ladies think it was just a mistake? I've been listening since day one. Your breakdowns used to make me feel like I was watching the office while I was at work. Well, first of all, Dylan, this is a very, very good catch. Like, a plus catch. Yeah. I went back.
我查看了《客户调查》和《缓解压力》拍摄剧本上的日期。对于《客户调查》，日期是9月10日。对于《缓解压力》，日期是12月17日。所以答案是，没有。《缓解压力》从来就没打算在《客户调查》之前播出。是的，我觉得这只是个小疏漏，你知道的？他们就是漏掉了。他们漏掉了。
I looked at the dates on our shooting drafts for both customer survey and stress relief. For customer survey, it was September 10th. For stress relief, it was December 17th. So the answer is no. Stress relief was never going to come out before customer survey. Yeah, I think it was just a blip, you know? They just missed it. They missed it.
但迪伦没有漏掉。迪伦一直在认真看。好了，非常感谢大家写信来。我们真的很喜欢这一集，也相信你们会喜欢。以下是我们对由斯蒂芬·莫昌特执导的《客户调查》的解析。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。我们是好朋友。
But Dylan didn't miss it. Dylan's paying attention. Well, thanks you guys so much for writing in. We really love this episode and we think you will too. So here's our breakdown of customer survey with Stephen Merchant. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends.
现在，我们专为你制作了终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们都会解析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的当事人才知道的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士。天哪，今天这集的办公室女士太棒了。我好兴奋能让大家听到。我也很兴奋能听它。我要一遍又一遍、一遍又一遍地听。
And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of the Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Boy, this is a good episode of Office Ladies today. I'm so excited for you guys to hear it. I'm excited to listen to it. I'm going to listen to it over and over and over again.
我们现在正在听我们自己的声音。今天我们要聊的是《客户调查》。这是第五季第七集。由莱斯特·刘易斯编剧，斯蒂芬·莫昌特执导。就是那个斯蒂芬·莫昌特。得了吧，正在听节目的你们。你们知道斯蒂芬·莫昌特是谁。对，英国版《办公室》的创作者。
We're listening to ourselves right now. Today we're going to be talking about customer survey. It is Season 5, Episode 7. It was written by Lester Lewis and directed by Stephen Merchant. The Stephen Merchant. Come on, you guys listening. You know who Stephen Merchant is. Yeah, creator.
拜访。我们得跟他聊聊，伙计们。我本该忍到问答环节再说的，但我等不及了。我等不及了。我们很努力地想保持镇定。但我们做不到。我们做不到。
of the British office. Come on. We got to talk to them, you guys. I was supposed to wait until Fastback Q, but I can't wait. I can't wait. We tried really hard to keep it together. We couldn't do it. We couldn't do it.
好吧，我们还是按流程来吧。剧情简介。吉姆和德怀特收到了差评如潮的客户调查，他们联手查明原因。他们真的写得很差吗？有什么隐情吗？是的，有点像个侦探破案故事。谁干的？
All right, we'll still go through the motions. Summary. Jim and Dwight received poor customer surveys, and they joined forces to uncover why. Were they really bad? Is something going on? Yeah, a little bit of a who done it. Who done it?
与此同时，潘和吉姆整天通过微型蓝牙耳机保持联系，安迪和安吉拉则做出了一些婚礼筹备决定。噢，是的，他们确实做了。他们找到了全天下最好的胸花。他们真的找到了。我太喜欢那个了。我们搞定他们了。我们搞定他们了。
Meanwhile, Pam and Jim communicate all day long via teeny tiny Bluetooth ear pieces, and Andy and Angela make some wedding plan decisions. Oh, yes, they do. They get the best tintest in all the land. They do. I loved that so much. We got them. We got them.
好吧。趣味事实一，我们拍摄这一集的周是2008年9月8日那一周。这是我们总共的第79集。我当时很好奇，我们“办公室女士”一共做过多少集了？我的天哪。我们做过多少集了？这是我们的第83集。你在开玩笑吧。太疯狂了，对吧？哇。两边都在逼近宏伟的第100集呢。我们可以办个派对吗？我觉得可以。萨姆，我们可以办个派对吗？当然可以。谢谢你，萨姆。萨姆，你可以担任办公室女士派对策划委员会（PPC）的主席。这对我来说成了一项任务。我的意思是，你今年拿到了最酷的圣诞树。得了吧。这倒是真的。你是PPC的主席。你不得不问萨姆我们能不能办个派对，因为他是唯一一个会来的人。我们做办公室女士的工作人员没那么多。如果萨姆不干，那我们就办不成什么派对。基本上就是萨姆和卡西。科迪，你会顺便过来吗，也许还有科林？会来的。我们得把艾尔也叫上。噢，还有玛丽莎。对。这些都是我们的铁子。我们还得举办“带孩子上班日”，因为我的孩子们真的很想来录音室。我们今天开车去学校的路上还在聊他们怎么想来，因为放暑假了。噢，让他们来这儿吧。对。
All right. Fast fact number one, we shot this episode the week of September 8th, 2008. It was our 79th episode overall. And I got curious, like, how many episodes of Office Ladies have we done? Oh my gosh. How many have we done? This is our 83rd. You're kidding. That's bonkers, right? Wow. We're like zeroing in on the big 100 in both cases. Can we have a party? I think we can. Sam, can we have a party? We sure can. Thank you, Sam. Sam, you can be head of the PPC for office ladies. This has become a task for me. I mean, you got the coolest Christmas tree this year. Come on. That is very true. You're head of the PPC. You had to ask Sam if we could have a party because he's like the one person who's going to come. We don't have very many people that work on office ladies. If Sam's not down, then we don't have much of a party. Pretty much it's Sam and Cassie. Cody, will you stop by, maybe Colin? Yeah. We got to get Ile on. Oh, and Marissa. Yeah. Those are our peeps. And we still need to have take your kid to work day because my kids really want to come in the studio. We were just talking about it on the drive to school today about how they want to come because summer break. Oh, let's get them in here. Yeah.
好吧，等等，这是一集大制作。我们待会儿再闲聊。好吧，我们待会儿再弄清楚那个。趣味事实二，斯蒂芬·莫昌特执导了这一集。什么？所以他和瑞奇·热维斯共同创作了英国版《办公室》。它在BBC 2台播了两季。每季六集，然后他们做了一部两部分的圣诞特辑。
Okay, wait, this is a big episode. We'll chitty chat later. All right, we'll figure that out later. Fast fact number two, Stephen Merchant directed this episode. What? So he and Ricky Jervase created the British office. It ran on BBC 2 for two seasons. They were six episodes each, and then they did a two-part Christmas special.
他们自己编写并执导了所有的剧集。是的。他们会带着录音笔坐在一起，对吧？然后他们会讨论场景并把它们记录下来。他们自己两个人写了整个系列。然后他们让我们拍了一个美国版。接着斯蒂芬执导了这一集。然后他同意来上我们的播客。
They wrote and directed all of the episodes themselves. Yes. They would sit together with a dictaphone, right? and they would talk out scenes and then transcribe them. They wrote the whole series, just the two of them. And then they let us make an American version. And then Stephen directed this episode. And then he agreed to come on our podcast.
哦，我的天哪。我是说，哇。为了给我们做准备，在听采访之前，我觉得我们应该先复习一些关于英国版《办公室》和美国版《办公室》的事实。哦，我喜欢这个。好的。所以英国版《办公室》的故事背景设定在。
Oh, my goodness. I mean, wow. To prep us, before we listened to the interview, I thought we should go over a few facts about the British office and the American office. Oh, I like it. Okay. So the British office was set.
一家名为沃纳姆·霍格（Wernham Hogg）的造纸公司。它位于斯劳（Slough）。他们用于节目外景的那栋建筑，位于斯劳贸易庄园，被称为十字弓大楼，但他们在2013年把它给拆了。所以你没法去参观了。当我们开展我们的英国办公室取景地之旅时，我们将没法去看那个地方了。好吧，我们可能不得不去那个地点看看。对。我们会指着那个地方。好的。那会是一张很棒的照片。你知道吗？我会把它放进我们的剪贴簿里。相比之下，邓德米夫林公司位于斯克兰顿，我们大楼的外景过去是、现在也仍然位于加州范奈斯的萨塔科伊斯街上的钱德勒山谷制片厂。你可以跟那个地方合影。
a paper company called Wernham Hogg. And it was located in Slough. The building that they used for the exterior of their show, it was located on Slough Trading Estate and it was called the Crossbow House, but they tore it down in 2013. So you can't visit it. When we do our England tour of office locations, we're not going to be able to see that one. Well, we might just have to go to the spot. Yeah. We'll point to the spot. Okay. That'll be a great photo. You know what? I'll put it in our scrapbook. Dunder Mifflin, on the other hand, was located in Scranton, and the exterior of our building was, and still is, located at Chandler Valley Studios on Sattacois Street in Van Ice, California. You can take a picture with that one.
你可以的。但作为对英国系列的致敬，邓德米夫林的地址被列为斯劳大道1725号。我知道。我一直很喜欢这个。太贴心了。太贴心了。甚至连那种假名片上都有。噢，对。对。
You can. But as a nod to the British series, the address of Dunder Mifflin is listed as 1725 Slough Avenue. I know. I always love that. It's so sweet. So sweet. It's even on like the faky business car. Oh, yeah. Yeah.
就像迈克尔·斯科特有定制名片一样。我可能拿了一张。我可能偷了一张。上面就有那个地址。好吧，当我们和斯蒂芬交谈时，我们会更多地讨论这两家公司。我们要开始了吗？好吧，我还有一个趣味事实。噢，我的天。
Like Michael Scott had business cards. I might have taken one. I might have stolen one. It has that address. Well, we will talk more about these two companies when we speak with Stephen. Should we get to it? Well, I have one more fast fact. Oh, my Lord.
好的，我们来吧。我知道。我太激动了。趣味事实三。这一集是由莱斯特·刘易斯编剧的。哦，是的。我找到了一个对莱斯特的采访，他在采访中谈到了当他知道自己写的一集将由。
Okay, let's do it. I know. I'm so excited. Fast fact number three. This episode was written by Lester Lewis. Oh, yes. And I found an interview with Lester where he talked a little bit about what it was like, knowing that an episode he had written was going to be directed by
斯蒂芬·莫昌特执导时，他是什么感觉。哦，我喜欢这个。我能听听吗？好的。所以他说，这一集的故事情节在斯蒂芬确定要执导之前就已经敲定了。所以在写剧本的时候，幸运的是，他完全不知道，比如，其中一个，是的。我可不想脑子里带着那个。我只想把我打算写的剧本写出来，不要有任何压力。是的。但当他发现的时候，他紧张极了。因为，你知道的，编剧要一整周都和导演一起走来走去。他们全程都在一起。这是一种非常亲密的关系。是的。我是说，我会吓得屁滚尿流的。是的，有点。但他说，当他遇到斯蒂芬时，他感到的任何紧张感都完全消失了，斯蒂芬参与了剧本的最终重写，
Stephen Merchant. Oh, I love it. Can I hear it? Yes. So he said that the story for this episode was already in place before Stephen was attached to direct. So as he was writing it, luckily, he had no idea that, like, one of the, yes. I wouldn't want that in my head. I would just want to, like, write what I was going to write without any pressure. Yes. But then he was so nervous when he found out. Because, you know, the writer gets to walk around with the director for the whole week. They're together the whole time. It's like a very close relationship. Yeah. I mean, I would be pooping my pants. Yeah, a little bit. But he said any nervousness that he felt totally disappeared when he met Stephen and that Stephen participated in the final rewrites of the script,
他希望斯蒂芬·莫昌特能和我们一起参与每一集的制作。哦，太暖心了。好吧，对此我不能同意更多了。我知道，我知道。他的精力实在是太棒了。既聪明、有趣又善良。是的。好吧，珍娜，稍后当我们解析这一集时，我有一个小故事想分享关于莱斯特的，因为他在一个场景中拯救了我。哦，他真的救了我。但现在我们要休息一下。等我们回来，就是斯蒂芬·莫昌特。
he wished that Stephen Merchant could be with us for every single episode. Oh, that's so sweet. Well, I couldn't agree more with that. I know, I know. His energy is just fantastic. So smart, so funny and so kind. Yeah. Well, Jenna, later when we break down the episode, I have a little story I want to share about Lester because he rescued me in a scene. Oh, he really did. But now we're going to take a break. And when we come back, Stephen Merchant.
我真不敢相信。我真不敢相信。我得接上这个。嗨。好吧，我觉得我应该说一声“办公室女士们好”。哦，嗨。谢谢。我好喜欢这个。我不知道你们有没有注意到，
I can't believe it. I can't believe it. I got to follow that. Hi. Well, I feel like I should say hello office ladies. Oh, hi. Thank you. I love that. I don't know if you've noticed,
为了向英国版和英国制作的《办公室》致敬，我戴着我的沃纳姆·霍格棒球帽，这是英国的邓德米夫林。然后，我还带着我的邓德米夫林马克杯，我相信这是剧组送给我喝茶的礼物。所以，你知道的，我只是想向大西洋两岸和两部剧集都致敬一下。你太棒了。我们太棒了。我们太喜欢这个了。好吧，让我们看看。
in honor of both the British and the UK versions of the office, I am wearing my my Wernam Hogg baseball cap, which is the Dundra Mifflin of the UK. And then, but I have my Dundermifflin mug, which I believe was a crew gift for my cup of tea. So, you know, I'm just trying to pay homage to both sides of the Atlantic and both shows. You're awesome. We are so awesome. We love that so much. Well, let's see.
为了开个好头，我想——而且我确信你已经被问过一百万次了——哪怕是关于第一次见到瑞奇。但我提起这个是因为你提到安吉拉和我，我们是一个二人组。你和瑞奇也是这个二人组的一部分。但有些人，当我们遇到他们时，他们就改变了我们人生的轨迹。我想到了，你知道的，列侬遇见麦卡特尼，对吧？就像，那是什么？哇，我这已经算是极好的公司了。这太令人兴奋了。正如你所说的那样，我心想，我很抱歉。我很抱歉。哇，哇，我们在篮球那一集里并肩坐在一起的时候。我当时没有意识到我对你会有这么大的影响。那是我们列侬和麦卡特尼的时刻，安吉拉。所以，斯蒂芬，我知道你是去面试做瑞奇的助理。
To kick things off, I thought that, and I'm sure you've been asked this a million times, even about meeting Ricky for the first time. But the reason I bring it up is because you mentioned Angela and I, we're rocking a duo. You're part of this duo with Ricky. But there are these people who when we meet them, they just change the course of our lives. I think back to, you know, Lennon meets McCartney, right? Like, what is that? Wow, I'm already an amazing company. This is exciting. As you said that, I'm like, I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Wow, wow, when we sat next to each other in the basketball episode. I didn't realize the impact I was going to have on you. That was our Lennon McCartney moment, Angela. So, Stephen, I know that you went into interview for a job to be Ricky's assistant
在一家广播电台。你走进门，遇到了这个人。你当时有感觉吗？有什么火花吗？宇宙发生了转变吗？嗯，这很有趣，因为正如你所说，我确实走进了一栋建筑去见他。但他很快就说：“我们去酒吧喝品脱啤酒吧。”我的天哪。没几个老板会这么干的。他当时正在招人。所以我立刻被他吸引了。我觉得这似乎是一种正确的方法。我们顺着路走下去喝了一品脱，然后聊了起来。我们似乎在音乐、喜剧等方面有很多共同的爱好。所以在这方面我们一拍即合。但随后他对我说了一句话，我觉得这很有启示意义。他说：“听说，我——这是一个广播电台。
at a radio station. You walk in the door, you meet this man. Did you feel it? Was there a spark? Was there a shift in the universe? Well, it was interesting because we, as you say, I did indeed go into a building to meet him. But he very quickly said, let's go to the pub for a pint of beer. Oh my God. And there aren't many bosses that do that. He was hiring me for the job. So I was immediately charmed by that. I thought that sort of seemed like the right approach. And we went down the road and had a pint and we got chatting. And we seemed to have a lot of sort of common loves of things like music and comedy and stuff. So we hit it off in that regard. But then he said something to me, which I think was revealing. He said, listen, I, this was a radio station.
我们俩都要在那里工作——他说，听着，我对广播一无所知。我是靠花言巧语混进这个工作的。我不知道自己在干什么。而你似乎有一点广播经验。如果你把所有的活都干了，我保证让你玩得开心。”而我，正需要一份工作，心想，听起来这笔买卖挺公平。于是我加入了电台，瑞奇基本上成了我的老板。
where we were both going to work. And he said, listen, I don't know anything about radio. I've sweet talked my way into this job. I don't know what I'm doing. And you seem to have had a little radio experience. If you do all the work, I'll make sure you have fun. And I, in need of a job, thought, that sounds like a fair deal. And so I joined the station with Ricky as essentially my boss.
如他所说，他确实不知道自己在干什么。但我们设法找到了一种工作关系，过了一会儿，我们虽然是幕后人员，但过了一会儿他们意识到我们的更大价值在于上广播。一旦我们上了广播，我们开始交谈，并且开始成为那种主持人，有点像你们那样，我觉得那就是我们开始更有意义的时候，我想那就是我们的——如果你愿意的话——幽默感、彼此的关系以及默契，我觉得就是从那时起真正开始在广播中发展起来的，然后从那以后，这就顺理成章、水到渠成了。并且我们的经历、认识一个最终以那种方式与你合作的人的经历，很大程度上，正如我确信你们所发现的那样，就是寻找你们所有的共同点。我想还有那些你们不喜欢的东西，你知道的，然后决定这些是我们喜欢的电影，这些是我们喜欢的喜剧，这些是我们不喜欢的。我想，最初这种搭档关系的很大一部分就是，
And true to his word, he did not know what he was doing. but we managed to find a sort of working relationship and after a little while we were behind the scenes guys but after a little while they realized that our better asset was being on the radio and once we went on the radio and we started talking and being and being kind of presenters kind of like you guys that was what I think we're all starting to make more sense and I think that was where our if you like our sense of humor and our relationship with each other and our rapport I think that's where it really began to develop sort of on the radio and then from then it was sort of, you know, it was plain salient, really. And so much of what we, our experience, so much of sort of getting to know someone that you end up working with in that way is I think just, as I'm sure you guys discovered, it's just finding all the things you have in common. And I suppose the things you don't like, you know, and sort of deciding that these are the movies we like, these are the comedy we like, this is what we don't. And I think that, so much of the initial sort of partnering was that,
就是找到那些东西，那种共同的基调。天哪，这真是一个伟大的故事。而且我觉得安吉拉和我在一起工作时发现的一件事就是，我们的优势和劣势是如何发挥作用的，我们在工作上的差异——我们都有很强的工作道德，但我们工作的方式不同。你认为是什么造就了你和瑞奇成为一个优秀的二人组？嗯，我觉得我比瑞奇稍微年轻一点。所以我有一种年轻人的野心，有一种说干就干的活力。当时，我们在做这个。广播节目，然后我晚上会去讲单口喜剧之类的，而瑞奇大概到晚上6点左右就会在家陪女朋友吃奶酪。
was finding that stuff, that common grain. Oh, man, that is such a great story. And also I feel like Something Angela and I have discovered in working together is like our strengths and weaknesses and how they, and our differences in our work, we both have strong work ethics, but we work differently. What do you think were some of those things that made you and Ricky a good duo? Well, I think I was a little younger than Ricky. And so I had a sort of youthful ambition and I kind of get up and go sort of dynamism. At the time, we were working at this. radio show and then I would go off and do stand-up comedy in the evenings and things, whereas Ricky would sort of be home eating cheese with his girlfriend by sort of, you know, 6pm.
而且我觉得，你知道的，他年长一些，已经安于某种固定的模式了。我觉得我有这种渴望在世界上留下自己的印记的急切心情。而且我觉得，但与此同时，瑞奇拥有的是一种未被发掘的、具有爆发力的才华，正等着被发掘，你知道吗？而我有一种稍微更有条理、稍微更死板的方法来处理事情。我觉得把这两件事结合起来效果很好，你知道的，我能够引导他度过一些比较无聊的写作部分，比如情节的构建和所有这些类似的事情。
And I think, you know, he was older and he'd sort of settled into a certain groove. And I think I had this kind of eagerness to sort of make my stamp on the world. And I think, but at the same time, I think what Ricky had was just a sort of untapped kind of explosive brilliance that was just sort of waiting to be sort of mind, you know? And I think I had this slightly more kind of structured, slightly more rigid approach to things. And I think it was his sort of his wild spontaneity and my kind of slightly more, you know, by the book approach. I think kind of bringing those two things together sort of work well, you know, and I was able to kind of chaperone him through some of the more boring bits of writing, if you like, the working of the plots and all those sort of things.
但与此同时，他有一种，他就是很聪明。他对人和对事情都很有见地，你知道的，他年长一些，所以他有一种大哥哥的特质，他也能把它带入其中。所以这真的是一种非常有趣的动态。我们互相支持，而且我们以不同的方式激发了彼此的创造力。
But at the same time, he had a kind of, he was just sort of smart. He was just wise about people and about, you know, he was just older, and so there was a big brother quality to him that he could bring to it as well. So it was just a really interesting dynamic. We sort of supported each other and we kind of, I think, sparked each other's creativity in different ways.
这在我们两个人的生活中都是一段非常令人振奋的时光，我想。斯蒂芬，你就是我的珍娜。好吧，就是这样。这就是我要说的。我就是你，斯蒂芬。我负责结构、任务和，
It was just a very exhilarating sort of time in both our lives, I think. Stephen, you're my Jenna. Well, there you go. That's what I was going to say. I'm you, Stephen. I'm the structure and the tasks and the,
而安吉拉负责轰轰烈烈。我就像，我们去喝杯啤酒吧。我们抛出一些想法来。而我就像，我跟你去喝杯啤酒，但我会带个笔记本。对，没错。是的。好吧，我记得第一次见你是在《办公室》早期、非常早期的片场。
And Angela's the boom, boom. I'm like, let's go grab a pint. Let's bounce some ideas off. And I'm like, I'll get a pint with you, but I'm bringing a notebook. Yeah. Right, exactly. Yeah. Well, I remember meeting you for the first time when you came to the set of the office early, early.
珍娜，那是哪里？你们在哪里见面的？是最初的卡尔弗城片场吗？难道不是吗？斯蒂芬，你还记得吗？我绝对认为那是第一季。是的，我们当时还没去那些声音舞台，对吧？我们在一个真正的办公大楼里。
Jenna, where was that? Where did you guys meet? Was it the original Culver City set? Wasn't it? Stephen, do you remember? I definitely think it was a season one. Yeah, and we weren't on those sound stages yet, right? We were in an actual office building.
没错。那是一个真正的工厂上方真正的办公室，对吧？还是一个真正的仓库？在真正的仓库上面。是的。斯蒂芬，当你们拍摄英国BBC版本时，你们不也是在一个真正的办公大楼里吗？难道隔壁墙那边没有真人在工作吗？这是真的，绝对是真的。
That's right. It was a real office above a real factory, is that right? Or a real warehouse? Above a real warehouse. Yeah. And didn't you guys, Stephen, when you filmed the BBC version, weren't you in an actual office building as well? Weren't they like people working on the other side of the wall? That's very, that's absolutely true.
虽然奇怪的是，我们在一个小型英国电视制片厂综合体内，但我们不在制片厂里面。我们在制片厂综合体里的一个真正的办公室里。是的，正如你所说，有些人对我们制造的噪音感到恼火，他们正试图专心工作。而我们就在那里，你知道的，跑来跑去、制造噪音、跳滑稽的舞蹈等等。所以，是的，这绝对是一个真正的办公室，它拥有这一切的优点和缺点，我想，它感觉很真实。我们希望它感觉非常有生活气息。我们希望，我们总是希望我们版本的办公室感觉像是一部已经拍好的纪录片。然后每个人都把它忘得一干二净。它只是放在某处的书架上。在BBC待了大约10年，然后某个人把它擦干净，说，把这个放到电视上放吧。所以我们希望整东西都有一种疲惫感。办公室应该感觉很累，人们、衣服也一样。当他们片场里的植物稍微有点枯萎时，我们总是非常兴奋。我们喜欢那个主意。那是英国人，那种英国式的方法。你知道的，你通过制作令人沮丧的节目来反映天气。这就是那个办公室所拥有的。它有一种稍微疲惫的感觉，因为它曾经是。
Although, bizarrely, we were within a studio complex, a small British TV studio, but we were not in the studio. We were in an actual office in the studio. studio complex. And yes, as you say, there were people sort of who were kind of annoyed by the noise we were making and we're trying to get on with a job of work. And we were there kind of, you know, running around and making noise and doing funny dances and whatever else. So, yeah, so it's definitely very much a real office and it had all of the, the pros and cons of that, I suppose, that it was, it felt real. And we wanted it to feel very lived in. And we wanted it to, we always wanted our version of the office to feel like a documentary that had sort of been made. And then everyone forgot about it. And it was just on a shelf somewhere. the BBC for like 10 years and someone dusted it off and was like, put this on TV. So we wanted the whole thing to feel tired. The office should feel tired, the people, the clothes. We always were very excited when the plants that they had on the set were slightly dying. We liked that idea. It was the British, that British approach. You know, you reflect the weather by just making shows that are depressing. And that was what that office had. It had a slightly tired feel because it had been
一个真实的地方。当你搭建一个布景时，人为地创造那种艺术感不知何故稍微更困难一些，你知道的，你总是在为此奋斗。所以它有那种美好的、有生活气息的质感。但显然，拍摄时也有局限性，有点困难，你知道的，也没有太多的活动空间，你知道的，所以有利有弊。没错。我们的摄影师谈到过这一点，我们拍摄最初的，你知道的，卡尔弗城片场的那个地方是一个真正的办公室，所以没有墙壁可以移动，你也无法移开任何东西。这真的增加了真实感。但那是你们见面的时候。你们是在试播集时见面的，也许吧，珍娜，或者在剧本围读会上。
a real place. And it's somehow slightly harder to create that art. officially when you build a set, you know, you're always striving for that. So it had that nice, lived-in quality. But obviously, also restrictive to shoot in and a little bit difficult and, you know, and it's not much elbow room and, you know, so it was pros and cons. Right. Our camera guys have talked about that where we filmed the original, you know, set in Culver City was an actual office, so no walls moved, and you couldn't pop anything out. And that really just added to the authenticity. But that's where you guys met. You guys met for the pilot, maybe Jen or the table read.
我记得为你们做过一次剧本围读。天哪，我是说，然后我记得我们订了一些食物，吃了一顿午餐，然后只是……是的，但我认为那时你们可能已经在拍摄了。是吗？我想你们当时可能正在拍摄。我有一张那时的照片，感觉你们当时在片场，每个人都在某种程度上……我确信你们可能在工作，而我们实际去拜访时，拍摄已经如火如荼地进行了。我觉得我们最初做很多事情都是远程的。
I remember doing a reading for you guys. Gosh, I mean, and then I remember we ordered some food and had some lunch and just... Yes, but I think you were maybe shooting by then. Were we? I think you were maybe shooting. I have a photo from that time which feels like you're on the set and everybody's kind of... I'm sure you're maybe working and we were up and running by the time we actually visited. I felt like a lot of what we did initially was remote.
我知道格雷格·丹尼尔斯来英国看望过我们，我们和他坐在一起聊了两天，我们海阔天空地聊，试图告诉他更多关于为什么我们为英国版本选择了某些东西的见解，以及它们将如何转化为美国版，以及美国版中相应的元素会是什么。这对我来说很着迷，因为有些事情我们以为全世界都是一样的。例如，办公室的概念，办公室里的一群人去参加酒吧问答，这里是一个非常传统的想法。作为一群人，你会去参加一个知识问答之夜。而且我记得当时，这感觉对格雷格来说不是那么熟悉，知识问答之夜或问答之夜的概念。我想也许现在它们更常见了，但我不知道那是不是那么，有趣的是，当他们在法国做了一个版本时，结果发现在法国，星期五晚上，星期五工作日结束时，香槟会在。办公室里拿出来。什么？
I know that Greg Daniels came and visited us in England and we sat with him for a couple of days and we sort of chewed the fat and tried to talk about how, you know, try to give him a better insight into why we had chosen certain things for the British version and how they might translate to America and what the versions, what the equivalence would be in America. And it was fascinating to me because there were things which we assumed would be the same all over the world. For instance, the idea of an office, a group of people in office going to a pub quiz is quite a traditional idea here. You'd go to a trivia night as a group. And that, I remember at the time, it felt like Greg, that wasn't as familiar to Greg, the idea of kind of the trivia night or the quiz night. And I guess maybe they are more common now, but I don't know that that was as, and it's interesting, it was when they did a version in France, it turns out that apparently on Friday night, at the end of the working day on a Friday, the champagne comes out in. an office. What?
而在法国，我想香槟就像法国的水一样。到处都是。我只是觉得这很有趣。你知道的，这些有趣的，你知道的，变化。是的。《办公室》现在在多少个不同的国家有版本？有一个法国版。有一个法裔加拿大版。
Where I guess in France, I think champagne is just like water in France. It's just everywhere. And I just thought it was fun. You know, just these interesting, you know, variations. Yeah. How many different countries is the office in now? There was a French version. There was a French Canadian version.
有一个以色列版。有一个，我相信，有一个印度版。哦，我的天哪。而且我想还有一个南美版，但我忘了具体是在南美哪里了。但令人沮丧的是，他们会给我们寄来这些复印件，但当然它们都没有字幕。所以只是用他们当地的语言说，我完全不知道它是好是坏。这一定太棒了。斯蒂芬，当你花点时间坐下来思考，
There was an Israeli version. There was, I believe, a, I think there might have been an Indian version. Oh, my gosh. And I think there's a South American version, but I forget where, exactly. exactly in South America. But it was frustrating because they would send us copies of these, but of course none of them had subtitles. So it was just speaking in their local languages, and I have no idea whether it was good or bad. It's got to just be so amazing. Stephen, when you take a moment and sit in that,
你去找这个家伙喝了一品脱啤酒，而多年以后，你们两个人的这个想法无处不在。到处都是。这一定让你感到非常谦逊。就像新冠疫情一样。哦，不。不，我知道你的意思。但我认为，是的，但我也觉得令人兴奋的是，尤其是当你们开始你们的版本时，你知道的，我们一直是我们的节目的粉丝，
that you went and grabbed a pint with this guy, and all these years later, this idea that the two of you had is everywhere. It's everywhere. It's got to be just so humble. Like COVID-19. Oh, no. Yeah, no, I know what you mean. But I think, yes, but I think also what's exciting about that, and I think particularly when you guys began your version, was that, you know, we always were a fan of our show,
但我们永远无法像观众那样观看它，因为我们太沉浸其中了。我们在那里。我们写了它，我们太投入了，我们无法与之保持任何距离。而我记得当他们寄来你们节目的季，你们节目的剧集时，我可以像粉丝一样观看它。
but we could never watch it as an audience watches it because we were too immersed in it. We were there. We'd written it and we were just too involved and we couldn't get any distance from it. Whereas I remember when they would send the seasons of your show, the episodes of your show, I could watch it like a fan.
就好像，我只是作为粉丝在欣赏它，而不是以创作者的身份。你知道我的意思吗？这非常非常令人愉快。这就像你设计了你理想的节目，然后让有才华的人去制作并寄给你。你知道我的意思吗？这有点像一个神奇的，就像你赢得了一场比赛。你设计了一个节目，然后有才华的人制作了它很多很多年。
It was like, I was like, I'm just enjoying it as a fan and not as a creator in the same. You know what I mean? It's very, very pleasure. It was like you get to design your ideal show and then go off and have talented people make it and send it to you. You know what I mean? It's like sort of like an amazing kind of like you won a competition. You design a show and then talented people make it for many, many years.
我最喜欢的经历之一是我们在拍完试播集后，我在伦敦。你和瑞奇请我在一个地方喝了饮料，是不是叫格劳乔俱乐部（Groucho Club）？没错，是的。好的。那真是太令人兴奋了。但后来我在地铁上，我拿起了类似于你们那里的《电视指南》的东西。我往里面看，里面有一篇文章讲美国将如何毁了《办公室》。里面还有一个小小的气泡图，里面有我的脸，把我跟露西·戴维斯（Lucy Davis）作比较。
One of my favorite experiences was after we filmed the pilot, I was in London. and you and Ricky grabbed drinks with me at, is it called the Groucho Club? That's right, yeah. Okay. And that was just so exciting. But then I was on the tube and I picked up what was like your version of TV Guide. And I looked in there and there was an article about how America was going to ruin the office. And there was a little picture of my face in a bubble comparing me to Lucy Davis.
里面有我们所有人的脸的气泡，具体列出了我们将如何毁掉这个节目。是的，我还留着它。我把它放进了剪贴簿里。现在我告诉你，珍娜，真正发生的事情是瑞奇和我特意制作了那个，
And there were bubbles of all our faces talking about how we specifically outlining how we were each going to ruin the show. Yeah, I still have it. I put it in a scrapbook. Let me tell you right now, Jenna, what really happened was Ricky and I had that manufactured specially
并把它放在地铁里，塞进地铁里，为了真正让你振作起来，好好干。但说起这个很有趣，因为我记得当它刚开始被讨论时，正如你所说，有很多关于“哦，美国要毁了这部剧”的讨论。然后，当你的节目开始在英国播出时，大家就有点“哦，它没有英国版那么好”。然后随着时间的推移，美国版已经远胜于英国版了。
and placed on the tube, planted on the tube in order to really make you buck up your ideas and do a good job. But it's funny you should say that Because I remember that when it was first being discussed, as you say, there were a lot of things about, Oh, America are going to ruin the show. And then there was, when your show started airing in the UK, it was kind of, oh, it's not as good as the British version. And then over time, it's become the American version is far superior to the British version.
这就是我们这里做事的方式。你知道我的意思吗？我们就像是，我们先把你捧高，然后把你打倒。所以，是的，现在美国版基本上是很受欢迎的版本。甚至连英国媒体也这么认为。我和瑞奇被视为那种，哦，那些人，那些人已经过时了。不。不。
This is the way we do things here. You know what I mean? We're like, we kind of build you up and then we knock you down. And so, yeah, now very much the American version is kind of the much-loved version. even by the British press. And Ricky and I are seen as kind of, oh, those guys were tired of those guys. No. No.
这太棒了。这太棒了。也许它会兜一个圈子回到原点。好吧，我记得当我们搬到山谷深处的钱德勒山谷制片厂时，在新的片场遇见你们。我永远不会忘记，因为你们是来吃午饭的，我们所有人都超级兴奋。我想那时配角演员们，我们实际上已经有了真正的合同。所以我认为我更有勇气走过去打个招呼，因为也许现在没有人会解雇我，因为我已经被长期签约了。而你们，我们当时正在排队打饭。
It's amazing. It's amazing. Maybe it'll come full circle. Well, I remember meeting you guys on the new set when we moved, you know, way deep in the valley, Chandler Valley Studios. And I'll never forget because you guys were coming for lunch and we were all super excited. And I think by now the supporting cast, we were actually, we had real contracts. So I think I was a little braver to like come up and say hi because maybe no one would fire me now because I was locked in. And you guys, we were going through the food line.
助理导演走到我面前说：“安吉拉，你是午饭后第一个进行‘独白访谈’的。瑞奇和斯蒂芬将会在那里。”我当时就想，哦，不。不，我刚鼓起勇气打招呼。请不要让我当着他们的面做独白访谈。瑞奇说：“哦，别担心。我砸嘴的声音不会太大。”然后他竖起食指。
And the assistant director came up to me and said, Angela, you're the first talking head up after lunch. And Ricky and Stephen will be here. And I just went, like, I was like, oh, no. No, I just got the courage to say hi. Please don't make me do a talking head in front of them. And Ricky said, oh, don't worry. I don't tisk too loudly. And he did his finger.
我就想，啊，哈哈哈哈。然后有点冒冷汗。但那真是……不过我希望，我们……最终我希望，你知道的，我觉得我们最终总是尽量在可以的时候给予支持。我们有点意识到，有这样一个……我想仅仅因为我们有英国口音。
And I was like, ah, ha, ha, ha. And then sort of broke into a cold sweat. But it was... I hope, though, that we... I hope ultimately, you know, I think we always ultimately tried to be supportive when we could. We were kind of aware that it was like there was this... I think just because we had British accents
而且我们从很远的地方来，感觉就像女王来访问一样。是的。我们意识到了这一点。我想努力确保大家意识到我们不是来评头论足或刻薄的。哦，不，你们太棒了。我们对你们能来片场感到非常兴奋。然后当你们来的时候，我想，你知道的，我们这周在谈论《客户调查》。当你们来到片场时，
and we'd come from a long way away, it was like the queen had come to visit. Yes. And we were aware of that. And I think trying to kind of, you know, make sure people realized we weren't here to judge or be mean. Oh, no, you guys were great. We were just a buzz about having you guys on the set. And then when you came, I guess, you know, we're talking about customer survey this week. When you came to the set,
我读到过你在我们实际拍摄前在编剧室待了好几个星期。是的，是的，绝对的。是的，我们总是问别人是怎么在《办公室》找到工作的。我想我们知道你是从创作开始的，但你最后是怎么导演这一特定剧集的？你还记得吗？嗯，我想无论我什么时候去，因为我过去常常在洛杉矶的时候就去串门，有时和瑞奇一起，有时没有。我尽量每个季度来一次并顺便拜访。我总是非常，我就是喜欢在编剧室里。因为在，你得记住在英国，你知道的，瑞奇和我一起写这个节目，而且只有我们两个。我们没有拍很多集，但是，你知道的，感觉像是很多艰苦的工作。而且，你知道的，只有我们两个。
I read that you were in the writer's room for weeks before we actually shot. Yes, yes, absolutely. Yeah, and we always ask people how they got their job on the office. I think we know you started by creating, but how did you end up directing this particular episode? Do you remember? Well, I think whenever I had visited, because I used to kind of visit whenever I was in L.A., sometimes with Ricky and sometimes without. And I tried to come, you know, once a season and stopped by. And I was always very, I just loved being in the writer's room. Because in, you got to remember in the UK, you know, Ricky and I wrote the show together, and it was just us. And we didn't do a lot of episodes, but, you know, it felt like a lot of hard work. And it was, you know, it's just the two of us
在伦敦这个寒冷的小办公室里。而当你来到一个美国编剧室时，有这么多人。这真是一个充满活力、令人兴奋的氛围。你只是和许多非常聪明、非常有才华的人在一起。各种想法在四处飞溅。这与英国的体验是非常不同的体验。我一直很喜欢那个。
in this sort of cold London little tiny office. And whereas when you come to an American writing room, there's so many people. And it's just a really buzzy, exciting atmosphere. You're just with a lot, very talented, very smart people. Ideas are sort of pinging around. And it's a very different experience to the British experience. And I always love that.
我一直都很喜欢置身于那种环境中。所以我想，我和格雷格曾有过关于执导某一集的对话，只是在时间安排上从来没有成功，或者我总是和瑞奇一起在做什么，或者我在英国在做别的事情，不管出于什么原因，我刚好有那一小段时间窗口，所以我想，在某种程度上
I was just always a fan of being in that environment. And so I think there have been conversations with Greg about sort of directing an episode and it just never worked out schedule-wise or I was always doing something with Ricky or I was doing something else in the UK and for whatever reason I had that little window of time and I think, so I think in a sense
我一直都很喜欢那种环境。所以我想我和格雷格曾探讨过执导一集的事，但只是因为档期问题一直没能实现，要么是我当时一直在和瑞奇合作，要么是我在英国忙别的。不管出于什么原因，我正好有了那么一小段时间窗口，所以我想，在某种意义上
that particular episode was the one that was up and when I could slot it in but I had those few weeks ahead of it and I just wanted, I just thought, well I really, I love being in the right room, I love being in that sort of environment. Let me come over and just absorb that. And I'm sort of really glad I did
那一集刚好在播出，而且时间也对得上，但我在这之前有几周空闲，我只是想……我当时就想，呃，我真的很喜欢那种真实的房间，我很喜欢那种环境。让我过去感受一下吧。而且我真的很高兴我去了
because I felt like I was able to contribute to the script of that episode. And again, like I say, I just really had a blast, just seeing how it worked and seeing the ideas, you're bouncing around the room and seeing how one idea becomes another and how jokes are
因为我觉得自己能够为那一集的剧本贡献力量。就像我说的，我真的玩得超开心，看着它是如何运作的，看着各种创意在房间里碰撞，看一个点子如何变成另一个，还有笑话是怎么
improved. And like I say, not something I'd really experienced in the UK-Kent. So it was a learning curve for me as much as it was a job, if you like. And do you remember any pitches from the room? I know there's one scene,
变得更好的。就像我说的，这在英国的《办公室》里是我没怎么体验过的。所以对我来说，这既是一份工作，也是一个学习的过程。你还记得当时在房间里提出的哪些点子吗？我知道有一个场景，
the Mr. Butlicker scene. Right. That was loosely based off a situation you had at a job where you had to do the train-up, right? That's right. That's right. I was working at a call center answering phones, and we had to have training for a week beforehand. And one of the things we had to do was one person went in one room and called another trainee, and one was the customer and one was the person working at the call center.
就是巴特利克先生（Mr. Butlicker）那个场景。没错。那大致是根据你以前工作时需要做培训的经历改编的，对吧？没错，没错。我曾在一家呼叫中心接听电话，我们在上岗前必须接受一周的培训。其中一项任务是，一个人进到一个房间里去打电话给另一个受训人员，一个扮演客户，另一个扮演呼叫中心的工作人员。
And I figured that in order to maximize this and kind of get the most out of it, I thought it would be useful to be sort of a challenging customer. A little bit difficult or ask difficult questions or go quiet sometimes just because that's what I wanted to learn. Because it's figured, you know, you're never going to be able to just follow a script that someone always is going to be kind of difficult. So I started playing difficult customers for the other trainee. So I would be a little angry or whatever it would be. And eventually the guy in charge of the training took me aside and said, I can't have you do this anymore because you're upsetting the other trainees with your characters and with your questions and with your attitude. And anyway, so I'd always been very amused by that idea that in the course of that sort of training, you'd get so into the role that it would overtake the training. Yeah.
我想为了把这个环节的效果最大化、尽量学到更多，扮演一个具有挑战性的客户应该会挺有用的。稍微难缠一点，或者问一些刁钻的问题，有时甚至故意不说话，因为这正是我想要学习的。因为你想过，在现实中你不可能永远只照着剧本走，总会碰到一些比较难对付的人。所以我开始为其他受训人员扮演难缠的客户。我会表现得有点生气之类的。最后，负责培训的那位负责人把我叫到一边，对我说：“我不能再让你这么做了，因为你的角色、你的问题还有你的态度把其他受训人员都惹毛了。”不管怎样，我一直觉得这个想法非常有趣：在那种培训过程中，你会完全入戏，以至于戏份喧宾夺主，盖过了培训本身。哈哈。
So I raised that as an idea. And it just seemed like a funny idea to have gym kind of deliberately need. needling Dwight in that way. And some of the writers went off and came back with that scene. And I really was so happy with that. I thought it was absolutely fantastic. I thought it was a really funny spin on that idea. I thought when we shot it,
所以我把这个当成一个点子提了出来。让吉姆故意用这种方式去挑衅德怀特，这听上去像是个挺搞笑的点子。然后有些编剧就去把这个场景写了出来，最后呈现出来了。我对那个成果真的超级满意。我觉得它绝对太棒了。我觉得这是对那个点子非常搞笑的一种演绎。我觉得我们在拍摄的时候，
I thought the three guys were just fantastic. I loved the fact that it was sort of longer than a lot of scenes are, traditionally in the show. We could just sit in that moment. And I think it's, in a way, it sort of escalates. And I just, I thought everyone kind of knocked out at the park. And I'm sure there was a version of that that we shot where either Steve or, I think it was Steve at the end just said, we got the butt-knicker account. Which I don't think we could ever squeeze into the finished cut.
我觉得那三位演员简直太棒了。我特别喜欢这个场景，它比剧集中很多传统的场景都要长。我们可以静静地沉浸在那个氛围里。而且我觉得，某种程度上，它的张力在不断升级。我真的觉得每个人都发挥得淋漓尽致。而且我敢肯定，我们当时拍过另一个版本，最后要么是史蒂夫，我觉得是史蒂夫，在结尾时说了一句：“我们拿下巴特利克这个客户了。”我觉得这个镜头最后无论如何也塞不进最终的剪辑版里。
But there was a lot of fun little improvs around the edges. And yeah, I just think when there's a sort of, when there's three great performers and a really funny idea like that, sort of given free reign, it's so thrilling to be there as a director and watch it happen. And that was, I just thought I was so satisfied with that. with that scene. It's so great. It's so great. Well, Jenna, do you remember, I remember Stephen when you were on set. We did rehearse scenes, and we had sort of been rehearsing for technical, for camera. But I felt like when you were there, we rehearsed really sort of the meat of the scene and walked through the scene. And I loved it. I had a few scenes with Andy, and I had that scene with Dwight, you know, where basically we're going to get married on Shrewd farms, and I'm so happy,
不过在拍摄边缘有很多非常有趣的即兴发挥。而且，是的，我觉得当有三位伟大的演员，再加上这样一个非常搞笑的点子，并且给予他们完全自由的发挥空间时，作为导演在现场看着这一切发生，真的会感到无比激动。那就是……我对那个场景感到太满意了。太棒了。真的太棒了。对了，珍娜，你还记得吗？我记得史蒂夫，你当时在片场的时候。我们确实排练过场景，而且我们基本上是为了技术和镜头进行过彩排。但我觉得当你也在场时，我们真的对场景的核心进行了排练，并且把整个场景走位了一遍。我太喜欢了。我和安迪有几场戏，我和德怀特也有那场戏，你知道的，基本上就是我们要在舒鲁特农场结婚了，我超级开心，
and we're flirting and it's very weird. But we rehearsed. And I wish that we had done more of that. And was that part of your routine when you guys filmed in England, were you rehearsing scenes before you shot them? We were. And I think also what I think I probably brought with me,
我们还在打情骂俏，感觉怪怪的。但我们排练过。我真希望当时能多排练几次。你在英国拍戏时，那也是你们常规流程的一部分吗？拍摄前你们会排练场景吗？我们会的。而且我觉得，可能我也带了一些……
which was perhaps a bit unnecessary, was I think I was still slightly hung up with this obsession with the kind of realism of what we tried to do. And not that your show wasn't realistic, but I think, you know, Rick and I became very obsessed about realism and naturalism and what was real and what might happen and what might not happen. And I think actually it was a sort of unnecessary obsession because in the end it's a TV show and, you know, it's just, you just do what's the funniest and smartest thing to do. And so I guess I was bringing with me this sort of this, we must, we must get to the truth of it, you know, and it's kind of like, wait a minute, aren't they wearing tiny little Bluetooth headsets that don't.
或许有点没必要的东西过去。我觉得我当时可能还是有点纠结于那种执念，就是关于我们试图呈现的那种现实主义。倒不是说你们的节目不现实，但我觉得，你知道的，瑞克和我当时对现实主义、自然主义，以及什么是真实的、什么可能会发生、什么不会发生，都有着一种狂热的执着。而现在回想起来，其实那是一种没必要的执念，因为到头来这只是一部电视剧，你知道的，你只需要做最好笑、最机智的处理就行了。所以我想我当时带过去的是这种观念——我们必须、我们必须触及事物的真相，你知道的，然后就会觉得像是在说：“等一下，他们耳朵上戴的那些小蓝牙耳机其实根本不存在啊。”
don't exist. Like, why am I so hung up on the realism of this? You know, and so I think I was probably bringing an unnecessary obsession with that, which I transposed from our version. And it's funny, because even when I look back at our version, it's not, it's not realistic. I mean, there's lots of completely absurd moments. But for whatever reason, we got that in our head. So I think probably I was bringing a bit of that to it. And I think what I hadn't anticipated is just that you guys were so in a groove by that point that you didn't need rehearsed. You didn't need directing. You know, you could do it just standing on your head. You knew the characters. is way better than me.
“为什么我要这么纠结于这种事情的真实感呢？”你知道的，所以我想我当时可能带过去了一种不必要的执念，这是我从我们的版本里带过来的。而且挺搞笑的，因为即使我回看我们那个版本，它其实也并不真实。我是说，里面有很多完全荒谬的时刻。但不管出于什么原因，我们当时就是认准了这一点。所以我想我大概把这种心态也带了一点过去。而且我当时没有预料到的是，你们到那个时候已经配合得太默契了，根本不需要排练。你们甚至不需要导演。你知道的，你们倒立着都能演。你们对角色的了解
And you could just slip in and out of it so kind of effortlessly that it just didn't need that sort of rehearsal or that kind of attention to detail, whatever it is. I could have just left you to do it and come back after lunch. So I think it was just, like I say, it was again, I think it's just slight naivity in a way about having not done American shows, particularly long-running shows, where at some point the cast are just so in sync with the show
比我深刻得多。你们能够那么毫不费力地进入和跳出角色，根本不需要那种排练或者对细节的种种关注。我完全可以把你们留在那里自己演，然后等我吃完午饭回来就行了。所以就像我说的，这再次证明，我觉得这只是一种轻微的天真，因为我之前没有拍过美国的电视剧，特别是那些长青剧，到了某个阶段，演员和剧集之间的默契度已经高到……
in the characters, they don't really need their acting. Well, I agree with you that we were sort of like, we were a machine at this time, season five, but for me and Jenna and I and the cast have talked about this, when we did rehearse with you, it sort of grounded us back down and got us back into character. And not that we would step out of character, because we could, like you said, we could go right to Angela Martin. I know her, right? Yeah. But I don't know.
和角色之间已经心有灵犀，他们根本不需要过多的演技指导。好吧，我同意你的看法，当时我们的确像一台运转良好的机器，正值第五季。但对于我和珍娜，以及我们剧组的其他演员来说，我们都谈论过这一点：当我们在你执导时进行排练，这其实让我们重新脚踏实地，找回了角色的状态。倒不是说我们会出戏，因为就像你说的，我们随时都能切换到安吉拉·马丁的状态。我很了解她，对吧？是的。但怎么说呢……
For us as actors, we got really. into it because it allowed us to, you know, like not to sound too actuary, but have the moment. That's the craft, right? And feel like you're really part of a production and kind of remind ourselves, oh, yeah, we're here to do this really cool show that's a mockumentary. And I don't know, I geeked out about it, Jenna. No, I agree with you, Angela, because by this time, it was season five. And, you know, at a certain point, it can feel like a comedy factory, a comedy factory, a Comedy TV show factory. And we never wanted that.
对我们演员来说，我们真的完全投入进去了，因为这让我们能够——不想显得太像学院派——好好体验当下的时刻。这就是表演的功力，对吧？并且感觉自己真正参与到了一部制作中，提醒我们自己：“哦，对，我们来这里是为了拍这部非常酷的伪纪录片。”而且，不知怎么的，我当时对此兴奋得像个狂热粉丝一样，珍娜。不，我完全同意你的看法，安吉拉，因为到这个时候已经是第五季了。而且，你知道的，在某个阶段，它可能会让人觉得像是一家喜剧工厂，一家喜剧电视剧制造工厂。而我们从来都不希望变成那样。
And we did always try to come back to that place of authenticity. And when you came in in this season and really reminded us of that, I thought there was such a value in it. And then also, I was so grateful that you directed this episode, Stephen, because it ends with this big Jim Pam. Alex art school guy seen you talked about the tiny Bluetooths that actually did not work. They didn't exist at the time. They were like completely like made up, right? Yes.
而且我们一直努力回到那种真实感。当你在这一季加入并真正提醒我们这一点时，我觉得这非常有价值。然后我也非常感激你执导了这一集，史蒂芬，因为这一集以吉姆和帕姆的一个重大情节结束。亚历克斯，就是那个艺术学校的家伙，你提到那些微型蓝牙耳机其实根本无法使用。当时它们根本不存在。它们完全是虚构出来的，对吧？是的。
But it's funny, isn't it now? Because, you know, now with the airport and these other things, you know, they're kind of standard issue, aren't they really? But at the time, that just seemed such a kind of crazy. That was probably something I was probably hung up on at the time. It was like, what is this? Is this the thing? Yeah.
但现在想起来挺搞笑的，对吧？因为，你知道的，现在有了苹果耳机和其他类似的东西，这些东西基本上都成了标配，不是吗？但在当时，那看起来实在是太疯狂了。那可能也是我当时比较纠结的一点。当时就在想：“这是什么？这玩意儿真的存在吗？”是的。
Does this, can these exist? And not only that, they probably would have been really. expensive because no one had them. Yes. And so we would be shooting these scenes, and it would either be like an AD reading the lines. So you'd be shooting John's side and I'm either off camera saying my lines so he can hear me or it was an AD reading the lines. But in that last scene in particular, when Alex comes in to Pam at Corporate,
这东西真的能存在吗？不仅如此，它们当时可能还非常昂贵，因为根本没人用。是的。所以我们在拍这些场景时，要么是由副导演来念台词。也就是说，你在拍约翰的戏时，要么是我在镜头外念台词好让他能听到，要么就是副导演在念台词。但在最后那场戏里，特别是当亚历克斯在总公司找到潘，
and Jim can hear him giving her this pitch that she should not leave New York. We spent hours on that. I mean, it felt like a whole day we spent on that. And the script had like seven alternates to that scene. It was bonkers. Didn't one, Jenner, wasn't he, like, professing that he actually wanted to be in a relationship with you? Wasn't, like, there a huge spectrum of, like, what Alex was going to say to you? Yes, it was that either the place.
而吉姆能听到他对潘说，劝她不要离开纽约。我们为那场戏花了几个小时。我是说，感觉我们花了一整天的时间来拍那场戏。剧本里关于那个场景足足有七种不同的备选台词。简直太疯狂了。珍娜，当时是不是有一个版本，他表白说自己其实想跟你在一起？难道不是吗？亚历克斯当时要对你说的话，范围其实非常广泛，对吧？是的，其中有一个版本的台词是，
was, he actually had a line where he said, it's always been you, Pam. I mean, that's heavy. And then there was this whole other version where he had no feelings for me. He was just really invested in my artistic life. And we were just... But did we shoot different versions?
他实际上对我说了一句：“一直都是你，潘。”我是说，这台词挺沉重的。然后还有另一个完全不同的版本，里面他对我是完全没有男女之情的，他只是非常关心我的艺术生活。我们当时只是……不过我们真的拍了不同的版本吗？
I can't, because I remember the discussion about that. And I feel like I was, it seemed odd to me the kind of big declaration of love. For some reason, I was uncomfortable with that. But what you've got to remember as well is I wasn't entirely up to speed on what had already been being built within the season because obviously I'd only come in for that one episode. But I just, there was something for me that disquieted me about the Declaration of Love. I think partly because I think it was something, whenever the kind of Jim and Pam relationship is threatened, particularly once you got together, I kind of, it just makes me uncomfortable. what it's like, it's like knowing it's like your parents,
我不大确定，因为我记得当时讨论过这个。而且我觉得，那种深情的表白对我来说似乎有点奇怪。出于某种原因，我对那样的情节感到很不自在。但你必须记住的一点是，我对这一季里已经铺垫好的剧情并不是完全了解，因为很显然我只是为了拍那一集才来的。但我总觉得，关于“爱的表白”这一段，有些东西让我感到不安。我想部分原因在于，每当吉姆和潘的关系受到威胁时——特别是当你们俩好不容易走到一起之后——我就会觉得很不舒服。这就好比……就好比知道……就像你的父母
kind of the idea that your parents might get a divorce. It's sort of, I'm not, I just, it makes me sad. The kind of threat to the threat to the relationship just makes me sad. And so the idea, I don't know, I was worried that it was a sort of artificial jeopardy. Like it didn't really count because there was no way that you were going to leave Jim. And so therefore we were sort of creating a phony drama. But that might be my miss memory.
可能会离婚的那种感觉。某种程度上，我不是……这让我感到难过。这种对关系的威胁让我觉得难所以，那个想法……我不知道，我当时担心这是一种人工制造的危机。就好像它根本不算数，因为你绝对不可能离开吉姆，所以我们实际上是在凭空制造一场虚假的戏剧冲突。但这也许是我记错了。
I don't remember. I don't, was it, was it, was it, was it, was it, was it, was it, was it, was it, was it, was it, was it, was it, was it, was it, was it, was it was it, was it, down by the time we filmed it, do you remember? I do remember. The version where he professes his love was in the script. And John and I felt like you did. We thought, where is this coming from? We don't need this obstacle.
我不记得了。我不知道，难道在拍摄的时候，那个版本已经被……被否定了吗？你还记得吗？我确实记得。他在剧中表白的那种版本确实在剧本里。我和约翰的感觉和你一样。我们当时想：这都是从哪儿冒出来的？我们根本不需要这个障碍。
And the one that appears in the show was an alternate. And so when we got to set, we were so excited that you were on our side. And we could be like, guys, Stephen Merchant, creator of the show. The whole thing, thinks we're right. But it was still like this discussion. And I feel like for a while we tried to do this Frankenstein version where there was a little bit of his feelings and a little bit of art school. But ultimately, I'm so glad that we picked the one that was picked. But having watched the show again in anticipation of this, it's a little odd that he declares, like you say, he's so invested in.
而最终出现在剧集里的那个版本其实是一个备选方案。所以当我们到了片场时，得知你站在我们这边，我们真的超级兴奋。我们可以说：“大家看，史诗级人物、本剧的创作者史蒂夫·麦钱特，整件事的创造者，也觉得我们是对的。”但当时依然存在争论。我觉得我们甚至曾试图搞出一个“科学怪人”式的版本——里面既有一点他个人的感情流露，又有一点关于艺术学校的内容。但最终，我非常庆幸我们选了最后播出的那个版本。不过，为了迎接这次重温而再次观看剧集时，你会觉得他居然大声表白——就像你说的，他那么热切地投资于……
your art school. Because it feels like when he comes into the office, that's right. He comes into wherever you're working in order to kind of have a word with you. That definitely feels like he's going to declare his stuff because probably we filmed it thinking that was what was going to happen. And then by the time he gets into the little side room with you, he's like, man, you've got to stick with that art. And it's kind of, yeah, it's a little, it's still probably a little of Frankensteiny. Well, it's also slightly out of the blue because we ended up cutting so much of my art school, which at the time when we filmed this, we didn't know that scenes with Alex and, you know, he had given me a couple of art pep talks already, but they never made it. So it is a little jarring, but it sets up a really nice story for Pam and Jim, which is that, you know, what does the art really mean to her? What did this New York experience mean to her?
你的艺术学校——这其实有点奇怪。因为感觉当他走进办公室时——确实如此，他走进你在的那里是为了跟你谈一谈。那感觉绝对像是他要表白了，因为很显然我们在拍摄时就是按照这个方向去拍的。然后等他跟你走进那个小房间时，他又变成：“噢，天哪，你必须坚持艺术这条路。”所以，是的，这感觉多多少少还是有点像个拼凑出来的“科学怪人”。好吧，这也稍微有点突兀，因为我们最终剪掉了太多关于我在艺术学校的戏份。当时我们拍这些戏时，并不知道后来会有跟亚历克斯相关的戏份被剪掉——他之前其实已经给我做了好几次艺术方面的打气鼓励，但那些内容全都被删掉了。所以感觉确实有点突兀，但它为潘和吉姆铺垫了一条非常棒的故事线，那就是：艺术对她来说到底意味着什么？这段在纽约的经历对她来说意味着什么？
And, you know, and this is going to kind of haunt her for a while. And that part I like about the scene. Yeah, you're right. You agree. And I think, yes, it's the idea of do you pursue a particular dream or do you be with the person you love and the two things pulling at each other is an interesting idea? Yeah. Well, I watched this episode again last night with my tweens, my 13-year-olds.
而且，这会在接下来的一段时间里一直萦绕在她心头。场景的这一部分我真的很喜欢。是的，你说的对。你同意吗？而且我觉得，是的，“你是该追求特定的梦想，还是该和深爱的人在一起”这个概念，这两种拉扯是一个很有意思的想法。对。昨天晚上我和我的双胞胎孩子——我那两个13岁的孩子——又看了一遍这一集。
And just when Alex says, hey, can I talk to you? Just that, like the fact that he went to Dunder Mifflin corporate and sought her out to have a private conversation, they were like, whoa. So it's, to me, it was a reminder that you don't have to do much to really convey emotion. And yes, Alex is saying you've got to give your art a shot. You can't do New York in three months. But it's clearly about so much more. And Jim can hear that. Jim knows. It's that. It's that. That dude thing when he's like, oh, he's into you. And so for me, it was everything we needed. We didn't need anything more.
就在亚历克斯说“嘿，我能跟你谈谈吗”的时候，仅仅是那一幕……他竟然特意跑到邓德米芬总公司去找她，为了跟她私下谈话，我的孩子们当时都惊呼：“哇。”所以，对我来说，这提醒了我：其实不需要做太多夸张的动作就能传达出真正的情感。是的，亚历克斯是在说你得给自己的艺术一次机会，你在纽约只待了三个月是远远不够的。但这显然远不止于此。吉姆能听到这些。吉姆心里清楚。就是那种……就是那种男人的直觉，当他心想：“噢，这小子对我有意思。”所以对我们而言，这就是我们所需要的一切。我们根本不需要更多多余的东西。
There was something in the script that didn't make it in that made me laugh, which is that while Alex is talking, Jim says, cough if you still love me. And I cough. Oh, that would have been great. Again, I don't want to take credit for things that weren't mine, but I feel like maybe I'm wrong about this. But my instinct is that the little tag on that when Dwight recognizes the brand of Bluetooth in Jim's ear,
剧本里其实有一段没能播出的内容，当时把我逗笑了。那就是当亚历克斯在说话时，吉姆说：“如果你还爱我，就咳嗽一声。”然后我真的咳嗽了。哦，那段如果播出来肯定超棒！再次说明，我可不想把不属于我的功劳揽到自己身上，但我感觉——也许我记错了——不过我的直觉是，关于最后那个小彩蛋：当德怀特认出吉姆耳朵上蓝牙耳机的品牌时，
I feel like I had some contribution to that because I felt like the scene originally maybe just ended with the sort of the kind of dot, dot, dot, and the drama of it. And I felt like it needed a little conclusion or something to just kind of take away from the sort of emotion of it or the drama of it or something. And also sort of slightly resolve the Bluetooth idea. Yeah.
我觉得我对那个情节也有所贡献。因为我当时觉得，原本那个场景可能只是以一种省略号的形式结束，带着某种戏剧张力就完了。而我觉得它需要一个小小的收尾，用来冲淡那种过头的情感或戏剧张力什么的。同时也算是对蓝牙耳机的设定做个小小的呼应。对。
Yeah, that wasn't in the script, Stephen. That, that wasn't. It was not. So that was clearly like an on-the-day thing, yeah. A pitch, yeah. I also loved the reveal of the coffee mugs and how, in fact, they had not gone to Kelly's party and how this had built within the episode. And you talked a little bit on the DVD commentary how you were so invested in shooting
是的，那个不在剧本里，史蒂夫。那真的不在。确实没有。所以那显然是拍摄当天临时想出来的点子，对吧？现场发挥的一个点子，对。我也很喜欢咖啡马克杯的揭秘，以及实际上他们根本没去凯利的派对，这个伏笔是如何在这一整集中慢慢建立起来的。你在DVD评论音轨里也提到过，你对拍摄
this coffee mug reveal. I was quite excited because there was a sort of mystery element. And I quite like that. It's funny, the project I'm working on the moment at the moment has a sort of thrillery element to it. It's the first time I've done that. And that little taster on the office of just sort of Jim as the detective kind of piecing things together. It was very pleasing to me and sort of seeing the Colombo, you know, seeing the evidence and the kind of the mind working. I don't know why I find that very, very fun and sort of yes, sort of seeding the cups early on.
这个咖啡马克杯揭秘的戏份投入了极大的热情。我当时确实挺兴奋的，因为里面包含了一种悬疑的元素。而且我挺喜欢这种感觉的。说实话，我现在正在做的项目里也带有一点惊悚悬疑的元素。这是我第一次尝试这种风格。而《办公室》里的那个小巧思——吉姆就像个侦探一样把各种线索拼凑在一起——这让我感到非常满意。看着他就像“可伦坡”探长那样，看着证据，脑子在飞速运转。我不知道为什么我总是觉得这个过程非常非常有趣，而且……是的，就是一开始先把杯子的线索埋下，
and then the kind of the sort of when Jim looks around the room and he sees the mugs on the different desks and then he rushes to the off, you know, just the idea of it having a little bit of a sort of, you know, like a kind of little bit of a sort of thrillery, um, NCIS quality to it, whatever. I just find that. That was fun. It was a kind of nice, it was a different kind of energy, which I, which I found very pleasing to do, I remember. I took my mug. I have it. Smart. Why not? I would hope that you've got all of your memorabilia from the show. and it's just in a giant warehouse somewhere. I didn't get a mug. I was at art school. Yeah, you were at art school. Oh, well. Oh, Stephen, this was so great to reminisce about this episode with you and just reminisce with you in general.
然后当吉姆环顾房间，看到不同办公桌上的马克杯，接着他冲向办公室……你知道的，只要想到这个情节带有一点点那种……你知道的，带有一点惊悚悬疑或《海军罪案调查处》的质感，无论如何，我都觉得这很有趣。这是一种很棒、很独特的活力，我记得当时拍起来让我感到非常满足。我把我的杯子拿走了。我留着呢。真聪明。为什么不呢？我希望你留下了节目里所有的纪念品，它们现在都安放在某个巨大的仓库里。我可没拿到杯子。我在艺术学校呢。对哦，你当时在艺术学校。好吧。哦，史蒂夫，能和你一起回顾这一集，还有一般性地和你叙旧，真的太美妙了。
Is there anything else that you would want to share? Well, the only thing that occurred to me, as I was watching it the other night, the thing that I was certainly reminded of, and I'm sure this was a trick that was used a great deal in your show. And I certainly we'd used it in our version. But I remember there's a moment, where Michael calls Jim in for his kind of customer, you know, survey appraisal.
你还有什么想要分享的吗？嗯，唯一浮现在我脑海里的是，前几天晚上我重看的时候，我绝对被勾起了回忆——我相信这肯定是你们节目中经常使用的一个小把戏。我们当然也在我们的版本里用过。但我记得有这样一个时刻：迈克尔把吉姆叫进办公室去做他的客户……你知道的，满意度调查评估。
And the camera kind of whips from Jim at his desk to Michael in the, in his office doorway, and then it whips back again to Jim at his desk. And I remembered watching it again, I was suddenly reminded that those were shot on two different days and that Steve had to leave for whatever reason. And we didn't have him for that following day. And so we shot him in the doorway and we whipped the camera off him. And then the following day, we whipped back onto what John at his desk and then tied the two together in the editing room. So it looks like it's happening in real time.
摄像机从坐在办公桌前的吉姆身上猛地摇到办公室门口的迈克尔，接着又猛地摇回给坐在桌前的吉姆。我记得再次看到这一幕时，我突然记起这两个镜头其实是分在两天拍摄的，因为史蒂夫当时无论出于什么原因必须提前离开。接下来的那天我们没有他的档期。所以我们先拍了他在门口的镜头，然后把摄像机从他身上猛地摇开。第二天，我们再把镜头猛地摇回到坐在办公桌前的约翰身上，最后在剪辑室把这两个镜头剪辑拼接在一起。所以看起来就像是实时发生的。
And I was just watching it kind of, and I was very pleased at how effective it was when I watched it again. Because I realized, hopefully only me and the editor know that's what happened there. I would have no idea. Yeah. Yeah. It was a very satisfying little trick. I remember Randall talking about the whip cut that this was their trick. Because because of you couldn't, so much of our footage is like a one or docu style camera work,
我当时一边看一边觉得，再次看到它的时候，对它的呈现效果感到非常满意。因为我意识到，希望只有我和剪辑师知道当时是怎么拍的。我要是观众绝对看不出来。对。是的。这真是一个令人满足的小把戏。我记得兰德尔谈到过这种“快摇剪辑”（whip cut），说这是他们的看家本领。因为……因为你无法……我们的许多素材基本上都是单机或伪纪录片风格的摄像机运镜，
it was really hard to cut. But if you did a whip, you could cut in a whip. And that was the way that they would be able to use two versions of a scene or something. That's right. Absolutely right. And it's very satisfying to do because it's sort of somehow you're playing a little trick on the audience and they don't realize. I don't know why that's so sad. It's right.
所以剪辑起来真的非常困难。但如果你做一个快摇镜头，你就能顺着快摇的动作进行剪辑。这就是他们能够在场景中运用两个不同版本素材的方法。完全正确。千真万确。而且这样做真的很有成就感，因为某种程度上你对观众开了一个小玩笑，而他们根本察觉不到。我不知道为什么这让人觉得这么过瘾。确实如此。
Well, I was just going to say, over the course of the whole series, you were such a champion for Jim and Pam, and I remember that so much. We talked about how that was true in this episode, but all the way to the end, you were always so invested in them. And I just say thank you, because your voice in the writer's room was really meaningful.
好吧，我本来想说的是，在整部剧集的过程中，你一直是吉姆和潘的坚定拥护者，我对此印象深刻。我们谈过这在这一集里是如何体现的，而且一直到最后，你对他们始终都倾注了极大的关注。我只想说谢谢，因为你在编剧室里的声音真的很有分量。
So thank you. Well, thank you. and thank you for such an amazing job and congratulations with your podcast. And I wouldn't mind just saying a final thought, which was just about Lester, who wrote that episode. Yes. You know, Lester Lewis, who so tragically died a few years after that.
所以谢谢你。哦，谢谢你，也感谢你们带来了这么棒的作品，祝贺你们的播客大获成功。我其实还想发表最后一点感慨，那就是关于莱斯特（Lester），他是那一集的编剧。是的。你知道的，莱斯特·刘易斯（Lester Lewis），他在那之后几年不幸去世了。
And I only knew him for that one episode, and that was the only time I'd work with him. But he was such a lovely man, and I just, you know, and whenever I think of that episode, it's kind of tinged with that beer sweet, you know, that bit of sweet after-taste, if you like. So, yeah, a little reminder. to him. Yeah. We loved Lester so much. Well, Stephen, I just want to say thank you. I mean,
我只通过那一集认识他，那也是我唯一一次跟他合作。但他是个非常好的人，每当我想起那一集时，心里总会泛起那种苦乐参半的感觉，你知道的，那种苦乐交织的余味。所以，是的，借此机会表达对他的怀念。是的。我们都超级喜欢莱斯特。好吧，史蒂夫，我只想说谢谢。我是说……
I feel like everyone in our cast was just like humbled that we got this job. We all felt like we won the lottery ticket. And you gave us that lottery ticket. You know, you and Ricky, and you forever changed our lives. Like, I'm like, I'm the person that's quick to laugh and quick to tear up. And and what you gave us and how you changed our lives and our families, just from having this idea, I don't know, I will never be able to say thank you enough. So thank you. Well, that's very sweet of you. But again, I, you know, it's, I think Ricky and I feel very proud of our version, but also of the American version. I think for me, I grew up watching and loving American shows, and I was hooked on, you know, mash and then Cheers and then Roseanne and then the idea of
我觉得我们剧组的每个人都对能得到这份工作感到诚惶诚恐，我们都觉得自己像是中了彩票。而正是你给了我们这张彩票。你和瑞克，你们永远改变了我们的生活。我是那种特别容易笑、也特别容易哭的人。你们给予我们的这一切，以及你们如何改变了我们的生活和我们的家庭，仅仅是因为你们最初有了这个点子……真的，无论我说多少次谢谢都觉得不够。所以，谢谢你们。噢，你真是太贴心了。但话说回来，我觉得……我和瑞克对我们的英国版本感到非常骄傲，对美国版本同样如此。对我而言，我从小就是看着并喜爱美国电视剧长大的，我迷恋上了……你知道的，先是《陆军流动医院》（M*A*S*H），然后是《干杯酒吧》（Cheers），接着是《罗斯anne》，而把我的指纹印在像你们这样的一部剧上——
of having my fingerprints on a show like yours, which stands in the lineage of those shows and is now as beloved by audiences as those shows. It's just incredible. And that's a testament to you guys and all the cast and all the crew and all the writers. It's far, it's gone way beyond what Ricky and I did. It's like you mentioned about Frankenstein earlier. But to us, we've always thought of the offices, it's like Frankenstein's monster. And we kind of created this thing in the lab and it went off and rampaged around the world on its own, you know, without us. And the idea that the show is having this kind of, this sort of whole second life and, you know, audiences finding it again.
它传承了那些优秀剧集的衣钵，并且如今也像那些剧集一样深受观众喜爱——这简直太不可思议了。这完全要归功于你们、所有的演员、所有的剧组人员以及所有的编剧。它已经远远超出了瑞克和我当年的创作。就像你刚才提到“科学怪人”一样。对我们来说，我们一直把《办公室》视为科学怪人的怪物。我们在实验室里创造了这个东西，然后它就自己跑出去，在全世界到处大闹了一场，你知道的，没有我们的参与。而这个节目能迎来这样一种……可以说是迎来整个第二生命，观众们重新发现了它，
I just think it's such a thrill and an honor to be, to be associated with it. So, thank you. And will you tell us a little bit about the show that you're working on now, the offenders? Yeah. No, no, goodbye. Oh, dear. Come on. Well, it's interesting because it's a show that is about people doing community service.
我觉得能够与它产生关联，真的是一件令人激动且倍感荣幸的事。所以，谢谢你们。能给我们讲讲你现在正在制作的新剧《违法者》（The Offenders）吗？好啦，不聊了，再见。噢，天哪。拜托。好吧，有趣的是，这部剧讲的是人们去做社区服务的故事。
You know when you get like a DUI or some minor crime, and instead of sending you to jail, they give you 120 hours of picking up garbage at the side of the road or whatever. And my parents used to be, my parents didn't, they did not do DOIs. They were people that were in charge of offenders that did these days. And I just thought it was always an interesting idea, a good way of bringing a completely disparate group of people together. And interestingly, it has parallels with the office in that regard because, you know, like with an office, those people only know each other because they work in that same
你知道当有人因为酒驾或其他轻微犯罪被判刑时，法院不把他们送进监狱，而是判他们120小时在路边捡垃圾之类的工作。我的父母以前……我的父母可没有酒驾。他们是负责管理那些需要做社区服刑的违法者的工作人员。我一直觉得这是一个很有意思的概念，也是一个将一群完全不同的人聚集在一起的好方法。有趣的是，从这个角度来看，它和《办公室》有相似之处。因为，就像在办公室里一样，那些人之所以互相认识，仅仅是因为他们在那同一个
environment and they fall in love and they hate each other and they fight and argue and it's the only thing that keeps them together is because of that job and those four walls. And this was sort of a similar idea in a way is that although it has a bit more of a dramatic thrillery spine, the jumping off point is again, how do you bring an interesting bunch of characters together that wouldn't otherwise meet and sort of watch the sparks fly? And so it shares some DNA with the office in that regard. But yes, we're sort of in the middle of filming it now and hopefully it'll be out later in the year. And where can we find it? BBC and Amazon
环境中工作，他们会坠入爱河，会互相憎恨，会吵架争执，而唯一把他们维系在一起的就是那份工作和那四堵墙。这部新剧其实也有点类似的想法，尽管它带有一点更强的戏剧惊悚主线，但它的出发点依然是：如何把一群原本绝不会相遇的有趣角色聚集在一起，然后看着他们擦出火花？所以从这个角度来看，它确实和《办公室》有着一些共同的基因。不过是的，我们目前正在拍摄当中，希望能在今年晚些时候播出。我们在哪里可以看到它？英国广播公司（BBC）和亚马逊
Studios, is that right? Amazon Prime and BBC, yes. That's right. And it may change at some point. Who knows? Maybe it's cast will change. I don't know. But at the moment, it's called The Offenders. And yeah, and it's shaping up really nicely. I'm excited. Well, I want to throw something out there too, because I'm a big fan
工作室，是这样的吗？亚马逊Prime视频和BBC，是的。没错。以后可能会有变动也说不定。谁知道呢？也许它的演员阵容会变。我不知道。但目前它的名字叫《违法者》。是的，它目前的进展非常顺利。我很期待。好吧，我也想提另外一件事，因为我是你的电影《为家而战》（Fighting with My Family）的超级粉丝。谢谢。这部电影2019年上映。我在大流行期间发现了它。真的非常、非常好看。你是编剧兼导演。所以在等待《违法者》播出的间隙，大家一定要去看《为家而战》。非常感谢。我为那部电影感到非常骄傲。我觉得它的效果非常不错，所以我很感激你的喜爱。好吧，史蒂夫，这次聊天简直太开心了。谢谢你。谢谢。真的太美妙了。叙旧的感觉真好。
of your film, fighting with my family. Thank you. It came out in 2019. I discovered it during the pandemic. It is so, so good. You wrote and directed it. So while you're waiting for the offenders, check out fighting with my family. Thank you so much. I'm very proud of that film. I think it turned out really nicely, so I appreciate that. Well, Stephen, this was just a joy. Thank you. Thank you. It was wonderful. It's so great to reminisce.
聊这些真的让人很高兴。如果不是重新看了一遍，我意识到自己真的已经忘掉了好多当时的细节，以及拍摄时带来的那么多乐趣。能够回头再看一遍，真的让人感到非常欣慰。好吧，非常感谢你，史蒂夫。非常感谢你今天的到来。谢谢你们，伙计们。非常感谢。太棒了，真是太棒了。我不知道，安吉拉，但我必须告诉你，做完那次采访后，我兴奋了好几天。我知道。这就是你需要了解的关于史蒂夫·麦钱特的一切。这个男人身上散发出的温暖和真诚。
It's really nice to talk about it. If I hadn't rewatched it, I realized I was completely forgotten so much of that and so much of the fun of shooting it. It was really pleasing to kind of go back and look at it again. Well, thank you so much, Stephen. Thank you so much for today. Thank you, guys. Thanks so much. From there, that was so great. I don't know, Angela, but I have to tell you, I was on a high for days after we did that interview. I know. Here's all you need to know about Stephen Merchant, by the way. Just the warmth and heart of this man.
他在英国版里是蒂姆和多恩的坚定支持者，在我们美版里则是吉姆和潘的拥护者。如果你需要证据的话，看看他戴着沃纳姆·霍格（Wernham Hogg）帽子的样子就知道了。我知道。居然是为了一档播客。而且他还带了他的咖啡马克杯，那个邓德米芬的咖啡马克杯。里面装着茶。我们得送他一些“办公室女士”的周边。我们必须得送。好的。好吧，那么我们是不是该开始剖析这一集了？
He really was the champion of Tim and Don on the British show and of Jim and Pam on our show. And if you need an example of that, just look at how he wore his Wernham Hog hat. I know. For a podcast. And it brought his coffee mug, his Dunder Mifflin coffee mug. That he had tea in. We need to send him some office. ladies like merge. We have to. Yeah. Okay. All right. Well, should we break down this episode?
是的。我们开始吧。这一集一开场就是一个非常搞笑的冷开场。德怀特冲进迈克尔的办公室，祝贺他订婚。恭喜你，迈克尔。然后狠狠地捶了他一拳。我知道。我觉得我孩子们要是想祝贺你的话，大概也就是这种方式。就会说：“你考试得了满分！砰！”德怀特真的就像个小孩子一样。是的，确实如此。达里尔有一段面对镜头的单采。他只是想确保我们大家都知道上周看到的是真的，迈克尔绝对没有订婚。是的，没有。事实上，他甚至愿意支持迈克尔去做心理治疗。可能确实需要一点帮助。是的，他有点为迈克尔担心。不过有一个被删减的片段是这样的：大家让迈克尔讲讲他是怎么求婚的。哦。然后迈克尔就开始了……
Yes. Let's get to it. This episode opens with a very funny cold open. Dwight bursts into Michael's office to congratulate him on his engagement. Congratulations, Michael. And like punches him hard. I know. I feel like this is how my kids would congratulate you. Be like, you aced your test. Pow! Like, Dwight is such a kid. Yeah, no, it's true. Darrell has a talking head. He just wants to make sure we all know that what we saw last week was true, that Michael is definitely not engaged. Yeah, no. In fact, he would help support his therapy. Might need a little help. Yeah, he's a little worried about him. Well, there is a deleted scene where the gang asked Michael to tell him about the proposal moment. Oh. And Michael just starts doing
珍娜，就是那种他开始越陷越深、编造出一个荒谬谎言的戏码。而且真的超搞笑。萨姆，你能放一下这段吗？你喝醉了吗？我是怎么求婚的？让我想想。嗯，我开车带着她去了纳舒厄，我当时带着戒指。一颗10克拉的大钻戒，非常漂亮，然后我双膝跪地，天空中划过一颗流星，刚好把那颗钻石照得像流星一样闪耀，我们当时正坐在一家餐厅里，我把钻石塞进了一个芝士汉堡里。
that thing, Jenna, where he just gets deeper and deeper into like a ridiculous lie. And it's, so funny. Sam, can you play it? Are you wasted? How did I propose? Let me see. Well, hi, drove her up to Nashua, and I had the ring. Big 10-carat diamond, it was beautiful, and I got down on my hands and knees, and a shooting star crossed overhead, and it just lit up the diamond like a shooting star, and we were in a restaurant, and I put the diamond into a cheeseburger.
哦。真美味。她咬了一口，开始噎住了。那我该怎么办？我接受过心肺复苏（CPR）培训，绕到她身后，开始做海姆立克急救法。完美。那枚10克拉的大钻戒从她嘴里“咻”地飞了出来，直接掉进她的鲜虾鸡尾酒里，不偏不倚正好套在她的手指上。几百万分之一的概率。
Ooh. Yum. And she took a bite, started to choke. So what do I do? I, CPR training, go around, start doing the Heimlich. Perfect. The ring, 10-carat diamond, pops out of her mouth, hits her shrimp cocktail right onto her finger. Million to one shot.
餐厅里所有的希腊人都开始尖叫：“欧帕！”（Whoopah！）意思是“恭喜”。哦。所以这到底是一家什么样的餐厅，里面既能点到芝士汉堡又能点鲜虾鸡尾酒？而且他们还在流星底下的室外。而且它是希腊餐厅。而且是希腊餐厅。
All of the Greek people in the restaurant start screaming, whoopah! Which means congratulations. Oh. So what is this restaurant where they have ordered a cheeseburger and shrimp cocktail? And they're outside with a shooting star. And it's Greek. And it's Greek.
你肯定知道那款著名的希腊鲜虾鸡尾酒，就在流星底下配着美味的芝士汉堡吃。我是说，真的……如果有机会，大家一定要去看这段被删减的片段，因为你会看到他一本正经地说：“然后发生了这个，然后……”你知道的。10克拉的大钻戒。是的，我知道。哇。哇。留在正片里的情节是，大家逼着他给妈妈打电话把这个好消息告诉她。
And you know that famous Greek shrimp cocktail out under the shooting stars with a great cheeseburger. I mean, I just, you could just, if you get a chance, watch this deleted scene because you see him being like, and then this happened. And, uh, you know. 10-carat diamond. Yeah, I know. Wow. Wow. What was left in the episode is that everyone makes him call his mom and tell her the news.
结果他妈妈觉得他又在撒谎。然后他说：“妈，拜访体谅一下嘛。”有几个细节。我不知道你们有没有注意到，在他跟他妈打电话的整个过程中，明迪（Mindy）一直躲在菲莉丝（Phyllis）的肩膀后面。你只能看到她的额头。这绝对是因为明迪当时笑场了。对，她在笑。没错。
And she's like, she thinks he's lying again. And he's like, Mom, come on. A couple of things. I don't know if you noticed the entire time he's on the phone with his mom, Mindy is hiding behind Phyllis's shoulder. You can only see her forehead. This is totally because Mindy was laughing. Yeah, she's laughing. Exactly.
我们还收到了来自萨布里纳、汉娜和保罗的粉丝提问，他们想知道冷开场里给迈克尔妈妈配音的是谁。这位是琼·斯奎布（June Squibb），她是一位非常了不起的性格演员。她甚至在2014年凭借在电影《内布拉斯加》中的出色表演，获得了奥斯卡最佳女配角提名。哦天哪。她还在关于施密特的电影里演过杰克·尼科尔森的妻子。她演得太好了。真的太好了。她太棒了。
We also had some fan questions from Sabrina, Hannah, and Paul who would like to know who voiced Michael's mom in the cold open. This was June Squibb, who is an amazing character actress. She was actually nominated for an Academy Award for Best Supporting Actress in 2014 for her role in the movie Nebraska. Oh, my gosh. She also played Jack Nicholson's wife in the movie about Schmidt. She's so good. So good. She's so good.
是的。哦，我们真是太幸运了。对，那是迈克尔的妈妈。好了，现在我们正式进入正片剧情。今天是客户满意度调查的时间。是的。凯莉把所有的客户调查档案都拿给迈克尔，顺便还带了一张她买的伴娘裙的收据。
Yeah. Oh, we were so lucky. Yeah, that's Michael's mom. Well, now we're getting into the episode. It's customer survey time. Yeah. Kelly brings Michael all the customer survey files and also a receipt to her bridesmaids dress that she had bought.
那段剧情真的把我笑惨了。好吧，他会处理的。哦，对。他全包了。结果他直接把收据揉成一团扔进垃圾桶了。所以整个故事的背景是，德怀特、吉姆以及所有的销售人员，他们手头都有这些客户满意度调查表，如果他们做得好，就能拿到奖金之类的好处，对吧？对。
That whole bit made me laugh so hard. Well, he'll take care of it. Oh, yeah. He's got it. He just crumbles it up and throws it in the trash. So the whole premise of the story is that Dwight, Jim, all the salespeople, they have these customer surveys and if they do well, then they get bonuses and things like that, right? Right.
所以利害攸关。珍娜，我有个问题想问你。好的。你会做那些客户满意度调查吗？比方说，如果你在某个应用软件、一封电子邮件或收据上看到提示，或者有人因为你买过东西而打电话给你，你会去做这种客户调查吗？极少会做。但偶尔，如果我和某位销售人员有过非常棒的互动，我想给他/她点个赞，那我真的会拿着收据回家。你知道的，他们通常会在上面把编号圈出来。然后我去完成调查，并在上面写下他们有多优秀。这绝对就是为什么我们能成为好闺蜜，因为我也会这么做。你们大家会做调查吗？每次都做吗？我尽量。这挺花时间的。确实很花时间。我曾经跟一个打来电话的家伙聊了很久。我们当时买了一台家电配送，然后他们安排了上门安装，接着他们打电话来询问你对他们的服务满不满意，对吧？我跟那个人在电话里聊了足足45分钟。
So stakes are high. Jen, I have a question for you. Okay. Do you do the customer surveys? Like if you get a prompt on an app or an email or a receipt or if someone calls you because you've purchased something, do you do the customer surveys? Very rarely. But occasionally, if I have a really great interaction with a salesperson, I want to give them like a kudos. So I will actually go home with my receipt. You know, they usually circle it. Right. And then I go take the survey and I say how great they were. This is totally why we're BFFs because I do that. I do the surveys, you guys. Every time? I try to. It's very time consuming. It really is. I was once on the phone with this guy. We had gotten an appliance delivery and then they do the setup and then they called to see how you liked their service, right? I was on the phone with the guy for 45 minutes. Saying what? Well, I did his survey and then we just had a heart tart. Josh came in and was like, are you still on the phone with the dishwasher?
聊什么呢？嗯，我做完了他的调查，然后我们就开始闲聊起来。乔什走过来问我：“你还在跟那个洗碗机客服打电话吗？”我说：“对啊。我做完调查了。”他还告诉我，其实很多人根本不做这东西。有时人们会直接挂他电话，有时会对他大喊大叫，或者有时会被他问的问题惹恼。嗯。而那些其实都只是一些标准问题。然后我说他是个非常不错的小伙子。我跟他聊了聊，你知道的，他最近几个月过得挺不容易的。这太符合你的性格了。不过说实话，我做的是那种线上的客户满意度调查。哦，对。所以我不会去做那种电话回访的客户满意度调查。哦，我超喜欢电话回访的调查。是的，这就是你的风格。我想深入了解你。不管怎样，这一集让我想起了这件事。然后我在想，不知道珍娜会不会也做这种调查。我真的会做。因为我以前也干过那行。我知道一个好评对往上爬有多大帮助。确实如此。我以前也做过。所以我很能感同身受。好吧，本集的另一条故事线是，吉姆有一个单采镜头，在镜头里透露了他和潘……
I said, I am. I did the survey. And he told me a lot of people don't do them. Sometimes they hang up on him or sometimes they yell at him or sometimes they get very offended by the questions he asks. Hmm. And they're just sort of standard questions. And I said he was really nice guy. I talked to him, you know, he'd had a tough few months. This is so you. Let me say, I do the customer surveys that are online. Oh, yeah. So I don't do like a phone call customer survey. Oh, I love a phone call customer survey. Yeah, that's you. I want to get to know you. And anyway, this whole episode made me think about that. And I was like, I wonder if Jenna does them too. I do. Because I worked in that line of work. And I know how like a good review, it boosts you up the ladder. It does. And I did as well. And so I think about that. Well, the other storyline going on here, Jim's going to have a talking head where it is revealed that he and Pam.
我说，我是。我做了调查。他告诉我很多人不做。有时他们会挂断他的电话，有时他们会对大喊大叫，或者有时他们对他提出的问题感到非常冒犯。嗯。这些基本上都是标准问题。我说他真的是个好人。我和他聊过，你知道的，他过去几个月过得很艰难。这太像你的风格了。让我说吧，我做的是在线客户调查。哦，对。所以我不会去做那种电话客户调查。哦，我很喜欢电话客户调查。对，这很符合你的性格。我想更好地了解你。不管怎样，整集节目都让我想起了这件事。我想知道珍娜是不是也做。我做。因为我从事过那类工作。我知道一个好评是如何让你在职场上晋升的。确实如此。我也做过。所以我会考虑到这一点。好吧，这里正在进行的另一个故事线是，吉姆将有一个面对镜头的独白镜头，在镜头中透露他和帕姆。
are wearing teeny tiny Bluetooth earpieces. Yeah, and this technology did not exist. No, the Mitsuashi B-400 is not a real thing. This is a faky tech alert. Faky tech alert, yeah. We talked a little bit about this with Stephen, how they were totally fake. So the way we did this was we shot John's side of these conversations first, and I would be off-camera reading my lines.
戴着微小的蓝牙耳机。是的，而且这种科技根本不存在。不，Mitsuashi B-400并不是真实存在的。这是一个虚假科技警报。虚假科技警报，是的。我们跟斯蒂芬聊过一些关于这个的内容，它们完全是假的。所以我们拍摄的方式是，先拍约翰在这几段对话中的戏份，然后我会站在镜头外读我的台词。
And then at the end of the week, we went to the corporate. set and we shot my side of it and then John was off camera. And Veda, our script supervisor, would have to take diligent notes because if there was an improvisation that we did, she would have to write it down so that we could remember to shoot my half of it when we moved over to corporate. Oh, man. So it was really complicated. It wasn't like there was a camera on him and a camera on me. Right. So that's how we did it. And by the way, I found out that this whole Bluetooth storyline was pitched by B.J. Novak. I, of course, had to Google what is actually the smallest headphone ever made?
然后到了周末，我们去了公司片场，拍了我的戏份，约翰则站在镜头外。我们的剧务维达必须做认真的笔记，因为如果我们有即兴发挥，她必须写下来，这样当我们转到公司片场时，我们才能记得拍我的一半。哦，天哪。所以真的很复杂。不像他身上有个摄像机，我身上也有个摄像机。对的。所以我们就是这样拍的。顺便说一句，我发现整个蓝牙故事线是B·J·诺瓦克提出的。我当然不得不去谷歌一下：历史上最小的耳机到底是什么？
Oh, yeah. According to the internet, you guys, and I don't know why I find this stuff interesting. This is like what's happened with us with office ladies. We talk about it. We see something. We're like, I want to know. What is the smallest headphone? According to the internet, Swedish headphone maker, Ear Inn, kicked off its consumer electronics show in 2021 by revealing the A3, true wireless earbuds. And according to EARN, they are the smallest and lightest headphones ever made. Sorry, Apple. Are they expensive? Do you know? I looked it up as like $190.190.
哦，是的。根据互联网的说法，各位，我不知道为什么我觉得这些东西很有趣。这就像我们在办公室女士节目中遇到的情况一样。我们谈论它。我们看到了什么。我们就会想：我想知道。最小的耳机是什么？根据互联网的说法，瑞典耳机制造商Ear Inn在2021年消费电子展上推出了A3真无线耳机。根据EARN的说法，它们是有史以来最小、最轻的耳机。抱歉，苹果。它们贵吗？你知道吗？我查了一下，大约是190美元。190美元。
What? For the smallest? For the smallest. But are they the best? Don't know that. Don't know that, guys. Just telling you, Earin claims to have the smallest. Now it's time for Dwight to find out how he did on his survey. And I have what I'd like to call a new catchphrase alert.
什么？就为了最小的？就为了最小的。但它们是最好的吗？不知道。不知道，各位。只是告诉你们，Earin声称拥有最小的耳机。现在是时候让德怀特看看他的调查结果如何了。我有一个我想称之为“新口头禅警报”的东西。
What is it? Sam, can you play it? All righty, Dwighty. All righty, Dwighty. It's my new catchphrase. I love it. I'm going to say it. All righty, Dwighty.
是什么？山姆，你能放一下吗？好吧，小德怀特。好吧，小德怀特。这是我的新口头禅。我喜欢它。我要把它说出来。好吧，小德怀特。
What's you got, Jenna? Well, I'll tell you, Dwight doesn't do well on his survey. No. And Michael's not joking. Even though Dwight has that queasy feeling that he gets when he sometimes is hearing a joke. Yeah, but he's not laughing. He can't be sure because he can't see himself. But, yeah.
你有什么要说的，珍娜？嗯，我来告诉你，德怀特的调查结果并不好。没有。而且迈克尔不是在开玩笑。尽管德怀特有时听到笑话时会有那种隐隐的不安感。是的，但他没有笑。他无法确定，因为他看不到自己。但是，是的。
It's very upsetting, but guess who else doesn't get a good review? Jim. That's right. Yeah. He is arrogant and smudge. A lot of smudgness. Yeah. Now, Jim turns off his little Bluetooth. Yeah, Pam's like, what, what's happening? Yeah. And then he has a talking head where he reveals some pretty big news that he was counting on this bonus because he's going to buy his parents' house. Pam doesn't know this. And also, clearly, it's going to put him in debt because he says, you know, know he's going to buy something he can't really afford. But he's also retiring his parents. Yeah, I guess they need the money from the house sale to retire. Then he gets on the phone with Pam. He tells her about the bad review. But not about the house. How do we feel about that? Am I opening a can of worms? I mean, you have that look on your face where you know exactly how you feel about it. I don't know why you're asking me. You just turn red. I know. I know. Because the This is going to play out. Well, you feel like a home purchase is a two-hander, not a one-hander.
这真的很令人沮丧，但你猜还有谁的评价不好？吉姆。没错。是的。他又傲慢又自以为是。非常自以为是。是的。现在，吉姆关掉了他的小蓝牙。是的，帕姆心想：什么，发生什么了？是的。然后他有一个面对镜头的独白，在那里他透露了一些相当重大的消息：他一直指望这笔奖金，因为他要买下他父母的房子。帕姆不知道这件事。而且很明显，这会让他负债累累，因为他说，你知道，他要买一件他其实负担不起的东西。但他也让他的父母退休了。是的，我猜他们需要卖房子的钱来退休。然后他给帕姆打电话。他告诉她糟糕的评价。但没有提房子的事。我们对此有何感想？我是不是在自找麻烦？我的意思是，你脸上的表情表明你非常清楚自己对此的感受。我不知道你为什么问我。你的脸都红了。我知道。我知道。因为这件事情的发展情况。嗯，你觉得买房是两个人的事，而不是一个人的事。
It's a big life moment. And not just because they're going to live in it together. And I think that people should pick out their living space if they're going to live in it. But also because it's a financial burden. Jim has just revealed this is going to burden him and then also Pam. And I think that something of that gravity you should speak about with your partner before you do it. I personally don't find large financial purchases that I then have to live in to be a romantic gesture. I probably shouldn't have bought you that RV.
这是人生中的一个重大时刻。不仅仅是因为他们要一起住在里面。而且我认为如果人们要住在居住空间里，他们应该自己挑选。还因为它是一个财务负担。吉姆刚刚透露这会给他带来负担，进而也会给帕姆带来负担。我认为如此重大事情，在你做之前应该和你的伴侣商量。我个人不认为那些我随后不得不入住的大笔财务支出是什么浪漫的姿态。我大概不应该给你买那辆房车。
I do love the RV, Angela. I wouldn't have had the table be exactly where it is, but I can live with it. I loved it. Thank you. I put the title in your name. How are those payments? We're kidding. I didn't buy her an RV.
我确实很喜欢那辆房车，安吉拉。虽然我不会把桌子放在它现在的位置，但我能接受。我很喜欢。谢谢你。我把所有权写在你的名下了。那些分期付款怎么样？我们在开玩笑。我没有给她买房车。
I didn't buy her an RV. But yeah, I think this kind of moment is what we call the two-hander guys. It's a two-hander life moment. Yeah, and I think this sort of speaks a little bit to where, you know, Pam was so heavily criticized for Alex's attention on her that she never reciprocated, right, in this art school story. But there's not a lot of criticism of, like, how Jim is partnering. And that's sort of where, I don't know, he gets a pass maybe because he's so, like, charming and it's seen as like romantic. Well, some people might see it as romantic that he's going to provide a home. But I think.
我没有给她买房车。但是，是的，我认为这种时刻就是我们所说的“两个人的事”，各位。这是人生中两个人的重大时刻。是的，我觉得这有点说明了，你知道的，帕姆因为亚历克斯对她的关注而受到猛烈批评，而她在艺术学校的故事里从未给予回应，对吧？但对于吉姆是如何经营伴侣关系的，并没有太多的批评。这就是，我不知道，也许他得到了原谅，因为他太迷人了，这被视为一种很浪漫的事。嗯，有些人可能会认为他要提供一个家是很浪漫的。但我认为。
But he's not really because it's a financial burden. I said butt. I had a butt coming. Which is also that, you know, when you're partnering with someone in life, the word is partner. Right? Yeah. It's not soloing. I'm not soloing with you.
但他实际上并没有，因为这是一个财务负担。我说了“但是”。我本来就要说“但是”。这也是，你知道的，当你与生活中的某个人结为伴侣时，这个词就是“伴侣”。对吧？是的。不是单打独斗。我不是在跟你单打独斗。
partnering with you. And Pam might have said, you know what, why don't we live in one of our apartments and save money for a bit? Or she might have said, listen, I get it. I love your parents. I want your parents to be able to retire. I agree to take on this financial burden to provide your parents with a great retirement. I'm in. That's right. But she never given that opportunity. She never got the chance. Because there was some celloing and not some partnering. Yeah. Yeah. Let's talk about what Andy's up to. He goes to get some coffee, but he can't find his mug because Jim's using it. It's his face.
是在和你做伴侣。帕姆可能会说，你知道吗，为什么我们不住在我们的某个公寓里，存点钱呢？或者她可能会说，听着，我懂。我爱你的父母。我希望你的父母能够退休。我同意承担这个财务负担，为你的父母提供一个美好的退休生活。我加入。没错。但她从未得到这个机会。她从来没有得到这个机会。因为有人在单打独斗，而不是在做伴侣。是的。是的。我们来谈谈安迪在忙什么。他去买咖啡，但找不到他的马克杯，因为吉姆在用它。那是他的脸。
But is it? I mean, smile. Smile like the mug. That was so funny. That made me laugh so hard. Jenna, what do I have here in my hand? You guys, Angela has her mug with the star and her little severe face. I took it at the end of the week.
但真的是吗？我是说，微笑。笑得像那个马克杯一样。太好笑了。把我逗得大笑。珍娜，我手里拿的是什么？各位，安吉拉拿着她的马克杯，上面有颗星星和她严肃的小脸。我在周末结束时把它拿走了。
Am I like the office klepto? I full on took it. It has sat on my desk at home for 15 years, and I keep my pencils and stuff in it. And I washed it out and brought it here today so I could drink out of it. So cool. In honor of the episode, Sam, do you see it? You're head of the PPC. You need to clock things like this.
我是办公室里的强盗吗？我完全把它拿走了。它在家里的桌子上放了15年，我把铅笔之类的东西放在里面。我把它洗干净，今天带到这里来，这样我就可以用它喝水了。太酷了。为了纪念这一集，山姆，你看到了吗？你是PPC（派对策划委员会）的负责人。你需要留意这种事情。
It's wonderful. Okay. Thank you. I don't have one. You don't have one. That is not wonderful. Thank you. You do have a mug, though, with the edge on it.
太棒了。好吧。谢谢。我没有。你没有。那可一点都不棒。谢谢。不过你确实有一个带边缘的马克杯。
I do have that. Thanks to you, Angela. I don't think we talked about that on the pod. We haven't. All right. I'll share. Angela got me a mug from The Edge, my favorite movie. I made it, guys.
我确实有那个。多亏了你，安吉拉。我觉得我们在播客里没聊过这个。我们还没聊过。好吧。我来分享一下。安吉拉给我买了一个来自《边缘》（The Edge）的马克杯，那是我最喜欢的电影。我成功了，各位。
I went on a website and I made it. It took you months. It has a picture of Anthony Hopkins and Alec Baldwin, and then it has a picture of the bear. And then it has the quote, what one man can do, another can do. And I gave it to her as a birthday gift. Yes. And that is the actual quote from the movie, even though I say what one man has done, another can do. I looked it up.
我上了个网站制作的。这花了好几个月的时间。上面有安东尼·霍普金斯和亚历克·鲍德温的照片，然后还有熊的照片。上面还有一句台词：“一个人能做到的事，另一个人也能做到。”我把它作为生日礼物送给了她。是的。这就是电影里的原话，尽管我说的是“一个人已经做过的事，另一个人也能做”。我查过了。
I got it right. You got it right. You got it right. And now Jenna can drink her mug with either the bear facing her or Anthony Hopkins and Alec Baldwin. And I use it on days when I need to get fired up. You know, when I, like, when we're writing our book. And I know, like, I have a tough day of writing ahead. And maybe I just, I'm not, oh, I just can't get into it. I'll get that mug, Angela, and I'll pour coffee in it. And I'll look at that bear. And I'll be like, I'm going to slay this bear today. You know, the quote from the movie is, we're going to kill a motherfucker. bear today. The bear is the book. The bear is the book. The bear is whatever you need to conquer in the day. Not today.
我答对了。你答对了。你答对了。现在珍娜可以用她的马克杯喝水了，无论是熊朝着她，还是安东尼·霍普金斯和亚历克·鲍德温朝着她。我在需要振作的日子里会用它。你知道的，就像我们写书的时候。我知道，比如说，我前面有艰难的一天写作任务。也许我只是，我不在状态，哦，我就是进入不了状态。我会拿出那个马克杯，安吉拉，我会在里面倒咖啡。我会看着那只熊。我会想：我今天一定要干掉这只熊。你知道，电影里的原话是：我们今天要去干掉一个妈惹法克儿。熊就是那本书。熊就是那本书。熊就是你一天中需要征服的任何东西。今天不行。
And it stares at me. Not today, bear. Not today, bear. Not today, Anthony. Who's Anthony? Anthony Hopkins. Charles. Charles.
它盯着我看。今天不行，熊。今天不行，熊。今天不行，安东尼。谁是安东尼？安东尼·霍普金斯。查尔斯。查尔斯。
You mean Charles. Charles. Well, Jim says, why don't you use the Snoopy mug? And Pam's like, no, that's my mug. But it's not even her mug. Her mug is the pink mug. I know. So I wrote here in my notes.
你是说查尔斯。查尔斯。嗯，吉姆说，你为什么不用史努比马克杯？帕姆说，不，那是我的马克杯。但那甚至不是她的马克杯。她的马克杯是粉色马克杯。我知道。所以我在这里的笔记里写了
Wait, did Pam bring her pink mug? to art school. Maybe Pam brought her pink mug to art school. Snoopy is her backup mug. Yeah, I buy that. This is more mug talk than you ever thought you might hear. There's going to be more, too, so just buckle in for that later. Also, Andy would like you to know about landing the greatest tentist for the wedding. Do you mean the Shangri-La tent to celebrate your wedding with excellence?
等等，帕姆把她的粉色马克杯带去艺术学校了吗？也许帕姆把她的粉色马克杯带去艺术学校了。史努比是她的备用马克杯。好吧，我信了。这是你这辈子听过的关于马克杯最多的谈话。后面还有更多，所以请系好安全带，稍后会听到。另外，安迪想让你们知道他为婚礼找到了最棒的帐篷租赁商。你是说香格里拉帐篷，用来举办一场完美的婚礼吗？
I screen grabbed it. That's what the website says. And let me just tell you a little bit about this tint, you guys. It's two stories and heated, and it has a bridal suite for his bridal suite. It's really simple and tasteful, a two-story tint. You know, it's the same tentist that Giuliani used for his first and third weddings. But Nana Mimi can't be in Canvas that long. Angela's not having it. No, no, no, no, no.
我截屏了。网站上就是这么说的。让我跟你们简单讲讲这个帐篷，各位。它是两层的，有暖气，并且有新娘套房，为了他的新娘套房。真的很简单、很有品味，一个两层的帐篷。你知道，这就是朱利安尼为他的第一场和第三场婚礼使用的同一家帐篷租赁商。但咪咪奶奶不能在帆布里待那么久。安吉拉可不答应。不，不，不，不，不。
Well, I have to share with you guys the scene between Angela and Andy. I couldn't do it. I literally couldn't do it. It's at 10 minutes, 10 seconds. Angela Martin has to say to Andy, you can have your tent, but only if it's in a field, a hand-tealed field. You still can't say it. I tried my hardest. Just now you said hand-tealed field.
好吧，我得跟你们分享一下安吉拉和安迪之间的那场戏。我演不下来。我真的演不下来。在10分10秒的时候。安吉拉·马丁必须对安迪说：“你可以要你的帐篷，但前提是它必须在田野里，一块人工耕种的田地里。”你还是说不出口。我尽了最大努力。刚才你说了“人工耕种的田地”（hand-tealed field）。
No, I didn't. I was trying so hard. You said tealed. Did I say tealed? Like tealed like the color. Okay, well. It's supposed to be tilled, hand-tilled field. Okay.
我没有。我真的很努力。你说了“tealed”。我是不是说成“tealed”了？就像“teal”（青色）那个词的颜色。好吧。它应该是“tilled”（耕种的），人工耕种的田地。好吧。
So here's what Angela could not do on the day. What I just read to you guys was what was exactly in the script. Right. Right. And if you watch the show, you know that's not. what I say. Because I think we did like 13 takes. My Southern kryptonite is a vowel in front of an L. You might remember filthy emails. Couldn't say those. So I kept saying a hand-tealed field, hand-ealed field. Hand-tilled field. So many times that Lester came over to me, who's so sweet, and he said, Angela,
所以这就是安吉拉当时做不到的事情。我刚才给你们读的内容正是剧本里的内容。对的。对的。如果你看过这部剧，你就知道这不是我说的。因为我觉得我们拍了大约13条。我的南方发音软肋是L前面的元音。你们可能还记得“filthy”（肮脏的）这封电子邮件。根本说不出那些词。所以我一直说“hand-tealed field”（人工耕种的田地），“hand-ealed field”。人工耕种的田地。说了太多次，以至于莱斯特走过来找我，他太好了，他说：“安吉拉，
it's hand-tled-teld-tilled-tilled. Tilled. Hand-tilled. Tilled. Like untill. Hund-tilled. I can't say what happens to me. I cannot say this word. And I said, and I looked at him and I like looked at his lips as he said it. I was trying so hard. Stephen Merchant is the director. I'm sweating bullets here. So I was like, okay, okay, I got it. I got it. Hand heldfeld. And so I said, you can have your tent, but only in, if it's in a field, a hand heldfeldfeld. Handheldfeld felt. Handheld failed. And it was like a disaster. Lester came over. I'll never forget. He sort of crouched down by my desk and whispered to me. me, Angela, why don't you just say a hand plowed field? And I said, oh, Lester, thank you. Thank you so much. And that's what made it in the episode, because I can't say hand-tailed field. You can't do it. I can't do it. Can you say hand-until field? Hand-until field. Anyway, that is how Lester rescued me in this scene. That's beautiful. I know. He saved me with hand plowed. Bless his heart. He did. We need to talk about this scene, which we did talk about with Stephen, the role play scene. William Buttlicker. Yes. We basically covered this with Stephen, but we did have a fan question from Danielle, Allison, Stella, and Allison, who wanted to know how much of this scene was improv and how much was scripted. So I went and looked in the script. Thank you, James Paedia. Yes, thank you, Jamesapedia.
是hand-tled-teld-tilled-tilled。Tilled。Hand-tilled。Tilled。就像until一样。Hand-tilled。我不知道我怎么了。我就是说不出这个词。然后我说，我看着他，当他说的时候我看着他的嘴唇。我真的很努力。斯蒂芬·麦钱特是导演。我当时急得直冒冷汗。所以我就想：好的，好的，我懂了。我懂了。Hand heldfeld。所以我说：你可以要你的帐篷，但只能在，如果它在一个田野里，一个hand heldfeldfeld。Handheldfeld felt。Handheld failed。这简直是一场灾难。莱斯特走了过来。我永远不会忘记。他蹲在我的办公桌旁，对我说：安吉拉，你为什么不说‘hand plowed field’（人工犁过的田地）呢？我说：哦，莱斯特，谢谢你。非常感谢你。这就是这一集最终呈现的样子，因为我说不出‘hand-tailed field’。你做不到。我做不到。你能说‘hand-until field’吗？Hand-until field。不管怎样，这就是莱斯特在那场戏中拯救我的方式。太棒了。我知道。他用‘hand plowed’拯救了我。上帝保佑他。他确实做到了。我们需要谈谈这场戏，我们和斯蒂芬谈过的那场戏，即角色扮演的那场戏。威廉·巴特利克（William Buttlicker）。是的。我们基本上跟斯蒂芬讨论过这个，但我们收到了来自丹妮尔、艾莉森、斯特拉和艾莉森的粉丝提问，他们想知道这场戏有多少是即兴创作，有多少是按剧本演的。所以我去查了剧本。谢谢詹姆斯百科（Jamespedia）。是的，谢谢詹姆斯百科。
The scene is entirely scripted. It's amazing. That is such good writing. It is such good writing. I was sure that Steve's little asides were improvised. His delivery is so spontaneous. Like when he says, it's up to you to change his mind. Yes.
这个场景完全是按照剧本演的。太棒了。写得太好了。真的太好了。我以前还以为史蒂夫的那些小旁白都是即兴发挥的。他的语气太自然了。就像他说，由你来改变他的想法。没错。
I thought that was an improv too. Scripted. Beautiful. So, so good. What wasn't in the script was, I am irate right now. That was not in the script. And there were a couple of other little lines, but they were always just like a play on what was already there.
我还以为那个也是即兴发挥呢。都是按剧本来的。太美妙了。真的太棒了。剧本里没有的是，我现在气死我了。那句台词不在剧本里。还有其他几句小台词，但它们总是根据已有的内容进行的一些发挥。
Right. But yeah, that scene is just beautiful. Next is a scene that we didn't talk about with Stephen, and I wish we had. It's that moment when Dwight peels his car out and tells Jim to get in. Jenna, I know. I meant to ask him about it. So he talked about it in the DVD commentary that he loved how absurd it was that Dwight was like, get in, and then peels out. And you really think they're going to just tear out of the parking lot and go.
没错。但是，是的，那个场景简直太美了。接下来是一个我们没有和斯蒂芬聊过的场景，但真希望我们聊过。就是德怀特把车飞速开出并叫吉姆上车的那一刻。珍娜，我知道。我本来想问他这件事的。他在DVD评论里说过，他觉得太荒谬了，德怀特说上车，然后车就飞驰而去，你真的以为他们会直接冲出停车场然后开走。
somewhere. And then they go nowhere. And then he wanted him to make like a hard left and just go into his parking spot. And Jim's like, what? And Stephen said he wanted it to be even bigger. He was like, can we do it even bigger peel out? But there just wasn't the space. Well, I found this interview with Lester where he said that originally they were just going to have them meet, that Dwight was just going to have him meet down in the parking lot and they were going to have this conversation. And that Stephen pitched, oh, guys, let's make it more interesting and do this crazy car maneuver. It's so funny. So, so, so funny. I did get a fan catch from Madeline R. She is pretty sure that Pam's car is in the parking lot. Oh, that's a good catch. In the scene. So I looked for it and it's so fast. I couldn't register it. But I bet, you know, they just would leave our cars there. Yeah. So I think there's a good chance that's there. Oh, for sure. I bet. Well, you know, one of the things I loved about the scene was Dwight is, you know, convinced someone might be listening. into their conversation. So he plays Jay Giles band, the song Centerfold, really loud. It just took me
去某个地方。结果他们哪儿也没去。然后他本来想让吉姆来个急左转直接开进停车位。而吉姆却说，什么？斯蒂芬说他希望场面能再宏大一点。他当时问，我们能把车开得更快更猛一点吗？但空间实在有限。嗯，我找到了莱斯特的一个采访，他说原本他们只是打算让他们碰面，德怀特只是在停车场和吉姆碰头然后进行这段对话。是斯蒂芬提议说，哦，伙计们，让我们把它变得更有趣，来个疯狂的开车特技。太搞笑了。太搞笑、太搞笑了。我收到了玛德琳·R的一个粉丝发现。她非常确定帕姆的车就在停车场里。哦，这个细节抓得好。在那个场景里。所以我找了一下，它出现得太快了。我都认不出来。不过我敢打赌，你知道的，他们会把我们的车停在那儿。对。所以我觉得那里面有车的可能性很大。哦，肯定的。我敢说。你知道的，我喜欢这个场景的原因之一是德怀特确信有人在偷听。
back. I'm like, where are my roller skates? I went and listened to the album last night. And you guys, if you haven't watched music videos from this time, go back. They're pretty special. They're real special. They're delightful. My kids were like, what are they doing? I'm like, you guys, this is a music video. Oh my gosh. I remember watching music videos on MTV. And then do you remember the VH1 pop-up thing? Yeah. Where they would pop up little facts on the screen. Yeah, I loved those.
他们的对话。所以他把J·吉尔斯乐队的歌《Centerfold》放得很大声。这直接把我
Me too. Our whole generation grew up watching music videos. Mm-hmm. It's wild. So now we're back in the office, and Dwight is on a sales call, but he becomes increasingly convinced that someone is listening to him. He's talking to a guy on the phone, who, by the way, I found out, was played by actor Steve Zissis, who, if he's...
带回了过去。我想，我的旱冰鞋呢？我昨晚去听了那张专辑。你们大家，如果你们还没看过那个时期的音乐录影带，回去看看吧。它们真的很特别。非常特别。太招人喜欢了。我的孩子们当时问，他们在干什么呢？我说，你们这些小家伙，这是一部音乐录影带。天哪。我还记得在MTV上看音乐录影带的情景。然后你们还记得VH1的弹出式小知识节目吗？记得。就是他们会在屏幕上弹出一个个小冷知识那种。对，我可喜欢了。
you don't know who he is, he is amazing. He is one of the stars of the movie Baghead, which he made with the Duplas Brothers. Then he went on to create the TV comedy togetherness with them. And he has a story by credit on the new film Cruella. I mean, he's part of that whole like mumblecore movement. We got the best actors just to be voices on the phone. What the hell? What the heck? Dwight is positive. It's Kelly. And he charges back there, right? Yes. And, And he finds her on the phone. And she's like, you can't just come into my nook and call me stupid. Get out of my nook. And then Pam over at the corporate offices goes, that's what she said. That's what she said. Okay, that was an improvised pitch by John Krasinski. Oh, cute. So I'm there and John is like, oh my gosh, it should be a, that's what she said. That's what she said.
我也是。我们整代人都是看着音乐录影带长大的。嗯哼。太疯狂了。所以现在我们回到了办公室，德怀特正在进行一个销售电话，但他越来越确信有人在偷听他。他在跟电话那头的一个家伙说话，顺便说一句，我发现那个演员是史蒂夫·齐西斯，如果
And so we did it. We saved it. And then when I went to the corporate offices, we shot my side of it. That is so cute. I love that. Well, they're about to really uncover some details here in this little mystery, because Jim has a conversation with Kelly and she doesn't have anything to say. He literally asks her about Daryl. Like normally she'd be chatty. And Pam is like, wait a second. Yeah. Why isn't she talking your ear off?
你不知道他是谁，他太棒了。他是电影《笨头笨脑》的主演之一，这部电影是他和杜普拉斯兄弟合作拍摄的。后来他和他们一起创作了电视喜剧《患难夫妻》。他还拥有新电影《库伊拉》的故事署名。我的意思是，他是那种微成本电影运动的一部分。我们请到了最棒的演员只为了在电话里献声。搞什么鬼？见鬼去吧。德怀特坚信那是凯莉。于是他气势汹汹地冲了过去，对吧？是的。然后，他发现凯莉正在打电话。凯莉说，你不能随随便便闯进我的小隔间然后叫我蠢货。滚出我的小隔间。然后帕姆在公司总部那边说，这话听着耳熟。这话听着耳熟。好吧，那是约翰·卡拉辛斯基即兴提出的点子。哦，真可爱。当时我就在现场，约翰就说，哦天哪，应该来一句，这话听着耳熟。这话听着耳熟。
You know, it's a good thing that Pam was in Jim's ear this day because he may have never figured this out without her, truly. Mm-hmm. You know what I mean? Well, the next scene really cracked me up because Jim goes to Ryan. Ryan's got to know what's up with Kelly, right? Mm-hmm. And Ryan, I fell in love with Ryan in this episode, Jenna. Yeah, you're with me now.
于是我们就这么拍了。我们把它保留了下来。然后等我去了公司总部，我们就拍了我那一侧的镜头。太可爱了。我好喜欢这个。好吧，他们很快就要在这个小谜团中揭开一些真相了，因为吉姆和凯莉谈话时，凯莉却无话可说。他甚至直接问她关于达里尔的事。按常理她应该很健谈才对。而帕姆却觉得，等等。对啊。她怎么没对你喋喋不休呢？
I'm with you. I'm with you. Because Ryan said, this may be love. He says, I don't play the politics game anymore, Jim. Can I tell you something? I played it full on in New York. I played at high stakes for keeps, made it to the top. Like, who is this guy?
你知道，多亏了这天帕姆在吉姆耳边提醒，否则没有她的话，吉姆可能永远也搞不明白这件事，真的。嗯哼。你知道我的意思吗？好吧，接下来的场景真的把我逗乐了，因为吉姆去找瑞安了。瑞安肯定知道凯莉是怎么回事，对吧？嗯哼。而且瑞安，我在这一集里爱上了瑞安，珍娜。对，你现在跟我站一边了。
And my favorite thing is, he's like, can I tell you what I learned as he takes a sip of coffee? So we never end up finding out what he learned. I'm so sad. I would love to know his lessons. But Jim sees the coffee mug. Yes. This is the Colombo starting to piece it together like Stephen talked about. Yes.
我跟你站一边。我跟你站一边。因为瑞安说，这也许就是爱。他说，我再也不玩政治游戏了，吉姆。我能告诉你点事吗？我在纽约时可是全力以赴。我玩的是高风险且动真格的，还混到了高层。天哪，这人是谁？
He also has a coffee mug with his face and the little star. And that's when it becomes clear that Jim and Dwight did not attend Kelly's America's Got Talent viewing party. These were the party favors. These were the party favors. And somewhere in her house, Kelly has. A mug with Dwight's face on it and Jim's. She probably smashed them. Oh, I didn't even think about that.
我最喜欢的一点是，他一边喝着咖啡一边说，我能告诉你我学到了什么吗？所以我们最终也没能知道他到底学到了什么。我太伤心了。我很想知道他的经验教训。不过吉姆看到了那个咖啡杯。没错。这就好比是科伦坡开始把线索拼凑起来，正如斯蒂芬所说的那样。没错。
Oh, yeah. She bought everyone mugs. And so these leftover mugs are sitting there just making her so angry every day. Mm-hmm. And she's finally, oh, revenge is a dish best served cold, Kelly. Well done. I know. Well, I want you to know, Jim figures it out.
他还有一个印着他自己的脸和一颗小星星的咖啡杯。正是在这个时候，大家终于清楚吉姆和德怀特根本没有去参加凯莉的《美国达人秀》观赏派对。这些就是派对伴手礼。这些就是派对伴手礼。而在她家的某个地方，凯莉藏着。一个印着德怀特脸的杯子，还有吉姆的。她大概把它们都砸了吧。哦，我甚至都没想到这一点。
He rushes over to Dwight and says, Dwight, you were right. And I loved this scene so much. Mm-hmm. Dwight is finally right about a conspiracy. And then like a 10-year-old boy, he's like, let's go get her. And Jim's like, wait. But first he does that crazy air kick at Phyllis. I know.
哦，对啊。她给每个人都买了一杯子。所以这些剩下来的杯子就摆在那里，每天都让她气得要命。嗯哼。她终于，哦，复仇是个冷盘，最好冷着端上来，凯莉。干得漂亮。我懂。好吧，我想让你知道，吉姆把事情查清了。
Well, also in that interview with Lester, he said that Rain improvised that air kick. He only did it one time, but it was so brilliant. That's the take they used. Of course he did, because if you guys watch the show, Dwight does that air kick whenever he gets real excited. He's done it in the stairwell before a big sales call. It's the happy air kick. Yeah. I'm going to start using it.
他冲向德怀特说，德怀特，你猜对了。我太喜欢这个场景了。嗯哼。德怀特终于在一场阴谋论上猜对了一次。然后就像个十岁的小男孩一样，他说，我们去收拾她吧。吉姆则说，等等。但在此之前，他对菲利斯做出了那个疯狂的空中踢腿动作。我知道。
Pump it up, air kick. Also in that interview with Lester, he said he was really proud of this mug idea. And he said that ultimately the writers knew that Kelly was going to sabotage the customer surveys because Dwight and Jim skipped her viewing party. But they couldn't figure out how the guys would realize this fact. They had originally talked about maybe having Dwight tap Kelly's phone and overhear something or maybe they would find like a secret recording device or something. But that's when Lester got the party favor mug idea. And it's really so genius. And then paired with the way Stephen
好吧，在莱斯特的采访中，他还提到雷恩是即兴做出了那个空中踢腿动作。他只做了一次，但实在是太精彩了。这就是他们最终采用的镜头。他当然会这么做，因为如果你看过这部剧，德怀特每次一兴奋就会做那种空中踢腿。他在一次重大的销售电话之前也在楼梯间做过。这就是快乐的空中踢腿。对。我也要开始用这个动作了。
directed it is just so great. Yeah. Two great people working together making a great moment. Yeah. We also got a fan question about this scene from Evan L. Did the cast do a photo shoot for the mugs? And if so, did they ask you guys to make weird faces because Oscar looks really bored on his. I don't remember a special photo shoot. We had done a publicity photo shoot, so maybe they used those images, but I'm looking at my face on the mug right now. And it's also possible that Phil just walked around and snapped pictures of us. It kind of looks like one of your publicity photos that maybe they color enhanced. I still have my publicity photo. Do you want me to do a side-by-side in stories? Yes. We'll vote, guys. Do you think it's the same picture? Or do you
加油，空中踢腿。同样在莱斯特的那次采访中，他说他为这个杯子的创意感到非常自豪。并且他说编剧们最终知道凯莉会破坏客户满意度调查，因为德怀特和吉姆没有去她的观赏派对。但他们一直想不出这俩家伙是怎么发现这个事实的。他们最初讨论过也许可以让德怀特监听凯莉的电话并无意中听到些什么，或者他们可能会找到诸如秘密录音设备之类的小东西。但就在那时，莱斯特想出了派对伴手礼咖啡杯的点子。这真的太天才了。然后再加上斯蒂芬的执导方式
think Phil just took my picture at my desk one day, because they did do that sometimes. Oh, they would. They would walk around and you'd just be sitting there and they'd snap a picture of you for something. We'll get to the bottom of it. Well, Jenna, Kelly's going to get called into Michael's office. And she's busted now. She is. Dwight wants her fired. Yeah. And Michael asked them to leave the office. You know, he's like, this is serious. I need you to leave the office. And then Michael says this. And I loved it so much. Michael says, I have an enormous amount of trouble. trying to get people to come to my place. And I hate it. I can't tell you how much leftover guacamole I've ended up eating over the years. I don't even know why I make it in such great quantities. And then he says, listen, just sit there and pretend to cry, right? Can you do that? Yeah. And then they both end up laughing. And it's a really sweet moment. It really is. And we got a bunch of people writing in to ask if that laugh after Kelly fake cries, if that was like a fake laugh or if Mindy broke. No, that was scripted. It's scripted that her fake crying made them laugh. Well, I'll say this. In rewatching this episode, like three times, right? Before today, I could hear Mindy's fake laugh and then her real laugh. Yeah. So if you watch it, she fake cries, she fake laughs, then Steve laughs as Michael and then Mindy laughs as herself. Yeah. Her real laugh definitely comes out. Yeah. So now we're at this scene at corporate, which we talked about a lot with Stephen, this scene where Alex comes to Pam's work, he's going to kidnap her,
简直太棒了。两个伟大的人合作创造了一个伟大的时刻。是的。我们还收到了一个关于这个场景的粉丝提问，来自埃文·L。演员们为这些杯子拍过照片吗？如果是的话，他们是不是要求你们做出生气的表情，因为奥斯卡在杯子上的表情看起来真的很无聊？我不记得有过专门的拍照。我们之前拍过宣传照，所以也许他们用了那些图片，但我现在正看着杯子上我自己的脸。而且也有可能是菲尔四处走动抓拍了我们的照片。它看起来确实有点像你的宣传照，可能被他们调过色。我还留着我的宣传照呢。你想让我发到快拍里做一个对比吗？好啊。我们来投票吧，伙计们。你们觉得是同一张照片吗？还是你
wants to see this art. He said wine and cheese, okay? That's all you got to hear. If someone says, midday, there's an exhibit with wine and cheese. That's not being friends. Yeah. Well, thanks to Jamesapedia, I saw all of the candy bag for this. How many were there? Ten. Ten alts for this scene. Yes. Oh, my word. I wanted to count because we kind of talked about it. Mm-hmm. And it was 10, 10 alternate scenes. And I swear we shot so many, so many versions of it.
觉得有一天菲尔只是在我的办公桌旁顺手拍了我的照片，因为他们有时确实会那样做。哦，他们会的。他们会四处走动，然后你坐在那儿他们就会顺手拍一张你的照片留作他用。我们会查个水落石出的。好吧，珍娜，凯莉要被叫进迈克尔的办公室了。她现在被抓包了。确实如此。德怀特想开除她。对。然后迈克尔让他们离开办公室。你知道的，他当时说，这很严重。我需要你们离开办公室。接着迈克尔说了这样一番话。我太喜欢了。迈克尔说，我费了九牛二虎之力。试图让人来我家。但我讨厌这样。我无法形容这些年来我最终吃掉了多少剩下来的鳄梨酱。我都不知道为什么我要做这么多。然后他说，听着，你们就坐在那儿假装哭泣，好吗？你们能做到吗？嗯。然后他们俩最后都笑了起来。这是一个非常温馨的时刻。确实如此。我们收到了一大堆人发信来问，凯莉假哭之后的那个笑，到底是假笑还是曼迪真的笑场了。不，那是按剧本演的。剧本里就写着她的假哭让他们笑场了。好吧，我得这么说。在重看这一集时，看了大概三遍吧？在今天之前，我能听出曼迪的假笑和她后来的真笑。对。所以如果你仔细看，她先是假哭，然后假笑，接着史蒂夫以迈克尔的身份笑了，然后曼迪以她自己的身份笑了。对。她真正的笑声绝对是流露出来了。好的，现在我们来到了公司总部的这个场景，我们和斯蒂芬详细聊过这个场景，也就是亚历克斯来找帕姆工作，他要绑架她。
And I remember doing these scenes with Rich. It was so grueling. And we really bonded. Like, Rich and I are great friends today, I think, because we went through this moment together. Yeah, you were in the trenches of trying to find this scene. Yes. Well, we should have Rich on and talk about it. We need to hear his side of things.
想看她的艺术作品。他说有红酒和奶酪，好吧？你听到这就够了。如果有人说，中午有个带有红酒和奶酪的展览。那可不是在交朋友。嗯。好吧，多亏了詹姆斯百科，我看到了这个场景的所有废案。有多少个？十个。这个场景有十个备选方案。是的。哦，天哪。我想数一数，因为我们之前聊过这个。嗯。足足有十个，十个备选场景。我敢发誓我们拍了好多好多不同版本的画面。
We do. shooting this crazy scene. Let's call them, Rich. Come on. So I feel like we really covered this, but we did have a fan right in. And I'm so sorry I didn't write down your name because I thought this was a really good observation. They were saying, wasn't Pam's art program three months long and she went at the beginning of the summer? How was she there for Halloween and how is she still there? Isn't it November now? This art school is a mystery. It's a mystery. Yeah. That's a good catch. I still want to know if she has parking. You know, these are things we're going to wonder about art school. Well, she's having to go into Manhattan for her corporate job because Pratt's out in Brooklyn.
而且我还记得和里奇一起拍这些场景。真的是太折磨人了。我们真的建立起了深厚的感情。我和里奇现在是非常要好的朋友，我想，就是因为我们一起经历了这段时光。是的，你们俩当时都深陷如何演绎这个场景的泥潭中。对。好吧，我们应该请里奇来聊聊。我们得听听他的看法。
Yeah. Well, we end this episode with Andy, Angela, and Dwight. Yeah. Because Andy has found the perfect place for them to get married in its Shrewd farms. It ticks all of the boxes. Angela gave him a list of what the wedding location had to include. Yeah. And Dwight tells them he thinks they should have the Excalibur package. It's going to have everything they need. Angela is clearly delighted. Andy is relieved. And Jenna, all I could think of when I watched the scene was Jim and Pam planned Pam's wedding to Roy.
我们必须这么做。拍摄这个疯狂的场景。我们给里奇打个电话吧。来吧。所以我觉得我们已经把这事聊得很透彻了，不过我们确实收到了一位粉丝的来信。非常抱歉我没有记下你的名字，因为我觉得这个观察真的很深刻。他们说，帕姆的艺术项目不是三个月长吗而且她是夏天刚开始的时候去的？为什么她万圣节还在那儿，而且现在怎么还在那儿？难道现在不是十一月了吗？这所艺术学校简直是个谜。是个谜。对。这个细节抓得真好。我还是想知道她到底有没有车位。你知道的，这些都是我们对艺术学校感到好奇的地方。好吧，她得去曼哈顿上班，因为普瑞特艺术学院在布鲁克林。
And now Angela and Dwight are going to plan her wedding to Andy. Oh, yeah. Right? Yeah. It's sort of a callback. It is. You know, there's another little weird callback in this scene. A lot of people wrote.
好吧，我们在这一集的结尾迎来了安迪、安吉拉和德怀特。是的。因为安迪为他们找好了举办婚礼的绝佳地点，也就是施鲁特农场。它符合所有的条件。安吉拉给过他一份婚礼场地必须具备的清单。对。然后德怀特告诉他们，他觉得他们应该选择“亚瑟王”套餐。那里应有尽有。安吉拉显然非常高兴。安迪也松了一口气。珍娜，我看这个场景时脑子里唯一想到的就是，吉姆和帕姆曾计划过帕姆与罗伊的婚礼。
in with this fan catch, that the Funeral Homes Director in Job Fair? Yes, he's in the album. He's in the album. He got married at Shrewd Farms. Yes. Well, Lester said in his interview that they loved this guy and they used him twice and they also thought it worked because the Shroutes get married in their own graves. So he felt that he would know about Shrewt Farms. Yeah, that's a great catch. Well, all righty, Dwighty. That was customer. survey. Thank you so much James Carey for sending me those scripts. I also got in touch with Randy Cordray on this one because I couldn't remember if the Bluetooths were real. I was so convinced. So I wrote Randy and I was like, they weren't real, right? No, they weren't real. They talked about it
而现在安吉拉和德怀特要帮她筹划她和安迪的婚礼。哦，对啊。对吧？对。这算是一个小小的前后呼应。确实如此。你知道，这个场景里还有另一个奇怪的前后呼应。很多人写信
quite a bit on the DVD commentary. And of course, a humongous thank you to Stephen Merchant. We love you. We love you. Please come back. Yes. And next week, we have business trip. Michael's going to Canada, y'all. And Rich, we're going to call you. Yes, Rich. You will be in business trip, an episode that your character does not appear. But we have questions for you. We do. And this is our podcast so we can do that. That's right. All righty, Dwighty, you guys have a good week. You are really loving that phrase. I said it one time too many, didn't I? Maybe, but I like that when you attach to something, you go for it. Thank you. All right. We'll see you next week. That was your extra long. Goodbye.
提到了这个粉丝发现，那就是《招聘会》里的殡仪馆馆长？没错，他在那个专辑里。他在那个专辑里。他在施鲁特农场结过婚。是的。好吧，莱斯特在采访中说他们非常喜欢这个人，所以用了他两次，而且他们觉得这样也很合理，因为施鲁特家族的人都是在自己的坟墓里结婚的。所以他觉得这个人会知道施鲁特农场的事。对，这个细节太棒了。好吧，好了，小德怀特。那是客户调查。非常感谢詹姆斯·凯里给我发了这些剧本。我也就这件事联系了兰迪·科德雷，因为我记不清蓝牙耳机是不是真的了。我当时深信不疑。所以我写信问兰迪，它们不是真的，对吧？不，它们不是真的。他们在DVD评论里讨论过
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Matt Beagle. Our Second Drinks episodes are produced by Molly Nugent. Our audio engineer is Sam Pfeiffer. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Shultz.
好多次。当然，还要非常感谢斯蒂芬·莫昌特。我们爱你。我们爱你。请再来做客。对。下周，我们要迎来《商务旅行》。迈克尔要去加拿大啦，各位。还有里奇，我们要给你打电话。对的，里奇。你将出现在《商务旅行》这一集里，虽然你的角色并没有在剧中出现。但我们有问题要问你。没错。这是我们的播客，所以我们说了算。没错。好了，小德怀特，祝大家过个愉快的一周。你真的很喜欢用这个短语。我好像用得稍微有点多余了，对吧？也许吧，不过我挺喜欢你一旦迷上某个东西就会坚持到底的性格。谢谢。好的。我们下周见。这就是你们超长版的再见。
Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Brue. Brad. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听《办公室女士的第二杯》。本期节目最初是与Earwolf合作创作的。《办公室女士》是Audyssey的一档节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的高级制作人是马特·比格尔。我们的“第二杯”系列节目由莫莉·纽金特制作。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·菲佛。Audyssey 执行制作人是利亚·里·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨进行混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是里尔·布鲁的《橡胶树》。布拉德。本集节目目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。